-
11:30     9:30 a.m. CST
May 18, 2017 l
Google I/
O
TensorFlow Frontiers
Stage 3
TensorFlow
iOS
Sierra
-
>> Hi, everybody, I'm Wolff
Dobson and I apparently can't
walk upstairs.  I'd like to talk
to you today about the
frontiers of TensorFlow.  It has
three parts.  The latest
developments in TensorFlow.
We're going to talk about Cloud
TPUs and TPU pods, and finally
Zak is going to tell us about
the TensorFlow Research Cloud
Okay.  So TensorFlow, it's
mentioner           machine
learning for everyone.  We like
to say that it is fast, it is
flexible and production ready.
When we say production ready,
what we mean is the code that
you mess around with on your
laptop, that you try out on your
local machine, it's the same
code that you push out to run on
giant clusters.  It's all the
same thing all the way down, no
rewrite ing in a new language
after you've figure ed it out
So, TensorFlow is this
language that allows you to
write computational graphs and
use these computational graphs
to do, usually, machine learning
and often deep learningSo here
is an example of, sort of, a
basic deep learn      learning
graph.  Here we have a picture
of a cat or a dog that we feed
in as pixels into the
convolutional layer at the
bottom, and then it goes all the
way down to give us a
prediction of some kind, either
it's a cat or it's a dog
Convolutional layers are one
kind of thing.  This is another
kind of thing.  This is a
collection of fully-
fully-connected layers, where we
have each node on each layer
connects to every other node on
the next layer
The arrows between nodes are
all weights.  Those weight
weights are -- we like to call
them parameters and they get
change ed over time.
This is a very deep network
where this is inception V3, and
inception V3 has about 17 layers
depending how you count, and it
has about 25 million parameters
, so it can take a while to
train.
And so what do you do when
you're doing TensorFlow, you
probably have Python, and you're
going to knock out some Python
there, and it's going to
generate this graph for you
you.  That graph, you're going
to execute later.  You're going
to execute it in two ways.ne,
you're going to be doing
training, which means you're
going to be showing examples and
modifying based on the results
you get, modifying those
parameters, and then when you --
then you can run it again later
on new data.  We call that
Inference, and we're hope ing to
get some kind of statistical
insight ought of          out of
all the data we have on this
new data
TensorFlow runs on all kinds
of platforms, CPU, GPU,
obviously, we're going to talk
about TPUs later.  They're
pretty neat
Also on mobile, iOS and
Android, and actually also on
ras berry           r  raspberry
pie, we can support all of
TensorFlow on that.  We support
all languages, Google supports
Python, C +  , Java and Go.
These others are community
projects, we're excite ed about
the community picking these to
use the new C bindings to create
new language wrappers
Floa come         TensorFlow
comes with a lot of different
tools.  This tool is tensorboard
, it's sort of like an X ray for
your training process.  It
allows you to look inside your
training and see what's actually
going on inside your graph
graph.  Thus you inspect your
graph, and in this case we're
showing off and embedding,
that's M nest, for those of you
that recognize it, it's handw
rite ing data, and you can see
we're grouping all the 5s as
gray and all the 9s adds redt's
really
as red really need to be able to
look and see what's actually
going on.  And, once you've got
this all trained up and you want
to push it into production, we
have TensorFlow Serve ing.
That's a second Open Source
project, also developed by
Google, that let's       lets y
ou kind of manage the process of
serve ing a model in
production, and it lets you do
things like serve multiple model
s in production, use it with
some kind of container engine,
and allows you to manage the
process of setting up one of
these big services
serviceses to allow you to do
insight for your customers is a
great talk about this.  I
encourage you, Noh    Noha Fidel
is going to be speaking about
it on Friday.
Inside Google, TensorFlow is
a   very popular.  This is a
graph of directors inside Google
with model description files in
it, which is to say, this is
like a little peetion of
piece of machine learning
we have inside the Google
repository.
You can see TensorFlow launch
ed in Q3 2014 internally.  We
actually had another system
before this, it was called disk
belief.  It was great but not
flexible enough for the kind of
projects we wanted to do, and
you can see after we launched
TensorFlow internally, there is
a kind of Explosion of trying to
apply ML to every kind of
problem at Google, search, gm
ail, translate, Maps, all kinds
of stuff
And in November of 2015, we
launched TensorFlow in public.
There we had the -- it quickly
became one of the most popular
-- actually, the most popular
machine learning GitHub project,
and when we say most popular,
we mean really the most popular.
(Laughing).  This is a graph
of all of our stars over time.
We're really ee happy
happy about community, and speak
ing of community, since November
2015, we've had 17,000 commits
from public, many of those from
external contribute ors
We have almost 500 non-google
contribute ors, and for
TensorFlow Version 1.0, which we
cuts      cut if    in
February, and we've actually had
some very significant external
commits.  One that comes to mind
is the Windows GPU Support was
actually external and it was
committed in and we absolutely
loved it
And if you hunt around on
GitHub, you'll find thousands of
other repository ies that have
TensorFlow in the title, and
along with that comes blogs and
books and all kinds of other
materials that, again, the
community is putting together
and we're so happy that they
are.
We also take supporting
TensorFlow seriously.  One of
the great things about working
on the the TensorFlow Team is
our engineering Team actually
takes rotations through stack
Stack Overflow and also
issues and PRs so we had over 5,
000  Stack Overflow questions
answered and about 5,000 GitHub
issues filed and triage ed in
some useful way, and we have a
lot of activity.  We're getting
almost 160 new issues a week.
So where are we today?  You
know, last night, or actually
yesterday afternoon, we branched
TensorFlow 1.2.  There is a lot
of new stuff in TensorFlow 1.2
around supporting TPUs.  Brennan
is going to talk about that,
but something that's come into
TensorFlow recently
recently is XLA, which is
TensorFlow's compile er for
accelerate ed linear algebra, XL
A, and the basic idea is
TensorFlow graphs go in   in,
and optimize ed assembly comes
out.  Machine code that will
actually run, it's not like an
optimize ed version of the graph
.  It is like it is an optimize
ed version of the graph, but
it's actually running in machine
code
Super important to support
custom hardware, and again we'll
talk more about this with the
TPU section.
TensorFlow is a distribute ed
execution engine that runs on
top of all of these other kernel
s for iOS, Android, GPU, CPU,
all of that kind of stuff.  On
top of that, we have the Python
front end, which is how you
program it.  We have a C++ front
end as well and all these other
languages
Recently in TensorFlow we've
added a layers API.   Layers API
gives you sort of big building
blocks that are the right shape
for you to do basic machine
learning tasks in the kind of
ways we've done, convolutional
layers, fully connected layers,
all that kind of thing
And, on top of that, we have
both Karas and Estimate ors.  Ke
ras didn't original at Google
but we liked it so much, it's a
high-level API that gives you
even sort of easy ier powerful
ways to fit all of these
different, all of your graphs
together, and then it's actually
built on top of our  Layers API
as well, and then we also have
Estimate ors, and  Estimate ors
are a way to package up and
abstract a way, sort of the
concepts of machine learning
learning.  It has Fit
and ee evaluate
Evaluate and all that stuff.
Again, Estimate is really
important for parallellization
And with Statementers,
Estimate ors, if you
want to do a linear regression
or classify ier or fully connect
ed layers, whatever ttion you
want                it is you
want, we might be able to give
you a canned estimate or that
allows you to do no graph
construction and just drop your
data and go.
The effect of all of these
high-level APIs, like Keras and
canned estimate ors, one of the
things you're going to see is
code gets smaller.  But beyond
that, like I said, a big thing
about Estimate ors, they help
you parallelize your computation
, and we're going to talk about
that more because TPUs are super
parallel.
Speaking of performance,
let's talk about performance.
About a week and a half ago, we
raised a bunch of benchmark
benchmarks.  They're
actually on TensorFlow.org,
there is a lipg down there.
link down there.
This is one of the graphs on
that page.  A video DGX1,
synthetic data 1, 2, 4, or 8GPU,
and there is a lot of throughp
ut there, a whole bunch of image
s per second.s per second is
super important.  Another thing
that's really important in
machine learning is that you get
good scaleup.  What that means
is if I add another GPU, do I
get another G.  Approximate
PU's worth of
performance out of that?
So in this graph, if you go
from 4 to 8GPUs, you actually
see double the performance.
It's a little hard to read on
this graph so we made it a
little easy ier, and an ideal
scale ing line on this graph,
and this is GPUs on one axis and
speed up on the other, and you
want with one GPU, you have 1X
speed up and 8GPUs, you have 8X
speed up and you want a straight
line all the way down there
On your test data, which are
common models in machine
learning, inspections, .  Are es
net            , Resnet50.
We're getting pretty close.
Next is synthetic data, you're
putting         put holding it
on constant, putting it on
cinder blocks and reving the
engine as fast as you can.
Add Google we think it's
important to try with real data
as well, on the right we have
the same test with real data,
and you can see it's not quite
as ideal.  It's never going to
be ideal because there is going
to be overhead for doing the
parallel competition
computation, but we're getting
pretty close
And if you want to scale up
to lots of GPU, we have bunch
bunchmarks for that as
well.  This goes up to 64GPUs.
This time on K80 in the Cloud.
Again, you're looking for that,
up, from 32 to 64, are you g
etting, you know, double the
throughput
But don't take my word for it
.  Try it yourself.  Not only
did we release the page that has
all of these bench
benchmarks and graphs on it, but
we also release ed the code so
you can dowrchload
download it and run it yourself
on your own set    setup.  We
have Google Compute Engine,
Amazon EC2, but please try it on
your own setup and tell us how
it goes.
Also, that code is tuned for
speed, so it's a good place to
look that if you're having, you
know, issues with scaleup, you
can take a look at our stuff and
see how we did it and see if
that can help you.
But, 64GPUs is a lot, but
there is more than 64 GPUs, and
with very large compute -- with
very large models, you're going
to need a lot more computation t
o train them, and that kind of
computation is more powerful
chips, faster communication
communication among
the accelerate ors, faster
memory and optimize ed software
stacko to tell you about that,
to tell you about TPU, which are
all of those things, I'm going
to hand it over to ZakThanks,
Wolff.  I'm super excite ed a
bout TPUs and I'd like to share
the story of their
develop        development with
you today.
Some of you may remember this
image here.  This is an image
of Google's first generation
TPU, which was reradio veel at
Google yoi last year and they
considered building custom as
soon as 2006 but it was more
urgent in 2013 when one of the
star engineers if all Android
users spoke to their phones for
three minutes a day that could
force Google to double the
number of data centers, so that
drove this crash project to
develop our first TPU, which in
just 15 months of building and
deploying these in the data
centers, brought us to some
pretty significant performance
gains across search, ranking,
Google Photos, Street View,
Google Translate, and a variety
of other large machine learning
applications.
In fact, compared to
contemporary CPUs and GPUs, this
first generation TPU was 15 to
30X faster on these internal
workloads     loads while being
30 to 80X more power efficient.
But there was an important
limitation, namely that this
first generation TPU was
designed for inference and not
training.  As Wolff mentioned
early ier, training is this
enormously complicate ed process
of setting all of these weights
in these giant machine learning
models, and then inference is
the process of running the ed mo
else, and so
the models, and while
the first generation was
excellent for running models
that were already trained,
Google still had to use huge
clusters to train the models 7
that       .
That inspired the second
generation, which is what was
announce ed yesterday.  This
device delivers up to 180ter
180teraflops of floating-p
oint performance and 64 gigabyte
s of ultra-high bandwidth
memory.  The most important
thing is that it's designed to
support most training and
inference on one platform, and
that turns out to be really
convenient because it allows you
to develop your model and then
run it in exactly the same way.
You don't have this barrier of
friction of having to quantize
the weights or figure out how to
deploy it it on a separate
platform.
But for some of Google's
large machine learning problems,
even 180teraflops isn't enough.
So from the beginning the
second generation TPUs were
designed to be connected
together with an ultra-fast
custom network.e call these
collections of TPU, pods, and
the TPU pods that you see here
contain 64 of these new second
generation TPUs.  If you add all
of that up, that gives you up
to 11.5petaflops of machine
learning acceleration that you
can apply to a single machine
learning training problem
problem, or you can split up to
support many different training
problems in parallel.
This whole system has 4
terabytes of term and the TPU
TPUs are connected in a droidal
mesh network that fas I will
state the ultra-fast and dense
communication that you need
especially to solve these
machine learning training
problems.e're already seeing
interesting results on some of
the important internal workloads
that matter to us.  For example
, on one of our new large-scale
nerl      neural machine
translation models it used to
take 24 hours to train the model
on the best commercialaly
available.  Now in 6 hours we
can train to the same accuracy
on 1/8 of a TPU pod. new devices
, these second generation TPUs,
we're thrilled to announce are
coming to Google Cloud as Cloud
tums.       TPUs.  Our goal is
Cloud to be the best Cloud for
machine learning, we offer
customers the choice for the
best hardware that you can find
anywhere, whether that's like S
scrk ylikeCPUs, Vola, and now
this new member of the family,
Cloud TPUs so customers can
build the best machine learning
systems to their specific workl
oads.
To tell you a little bit more
about how clowtd TPUs are going
to                   TPU
Cloud tup     TPUs are
going to integrate with
TensorFlow, I'd like to hand it
off to Brennan.
>> BRENNAN SAETA: Thank you,
Zak.  Today I want to talk to
you about Cloud TPUs.  Now, as
we've designed Cloud TPUs, we
wanted to ensure that it would
meet your needs, whether you are
a researcher or whether you're
designing a high-scale, high-
performance machine learning
product, so for researchers, we
wanted to ensure that it was
interact         interactive and
low level, can     you can play
around with your models and
debug them.
And for high-performance and
high-scale platforms and
products, we wanted to ensure
that it would integrate with the
rest of the Google Cloud P
latform.
But I think that instead of
me just telling you about it,
are it's more excite ing if I
show you.  Now, before I show
you, I want to say an important
caveat.
As we bring TPUs to Google
Cloud, there is a lot of move
ing pieces, and so some of those
pieces are still under active
development so things may change
.
That said, let's get started.
The simplest models that I
think I can show you is alpha
times X plus Y.
So alpha is the constant of 2
.  X is a vector, or we call a
tensor, of three 1s.  Y is also
three 1s, and we hope to at the
end of the computation get three
3s.
In order to use Google Cloud
TPUs      TPUs you've got to
first create one.  When you
create one, this is your Cloud
TPU.  And so, in order to access
it, however, you need to access
it via Google Compute Engine,
so we first create a virtues
iewl              virtual
machine in Google's Compute
Engine Product and we're going
to name it demo
vm and then we're going to call
a demo tpu.  We log into demo v
m, and this is what we see after
we install TensorFlow.o, we're
going to run the Python I
nteractive  Interpreter, and
we're going to import TensorFlow
just like normal.  After that,
we're going to connect to our
Cloud TPU using GRPC, Google's
Open Source RPC framework.
After that, you use
TensorFlow just like you
normally would, whether you're
on a CPU or GP
U.  The only
difference           difference,
however, is that you define
your computations that you want
to run on the TPU in this withtf
device block.  In doing so you
tell TensorFlow to run the
computation on the TPU.
After that, you can just run
it, again, just like normal
TensorFlow and it just works.
It's very comieting
excite ing.
So to review what just
happened, we logged into our
Google Compute Engine vm, ran
the TensorFlow and interact
interactive interpreter
and connected to the Cloud TPU
and ran the competition
computation and ferch
ed the result
ferched the results back to our
Google Cloud.his 1VM and Cloud
TPU is only the beginning.  We
designed Cloud TPUs to int
dprait with all the
integrate with
platforms available in the
Google platform. if you want, if
you have a model that part of
the model runs really, really
well on brand new GPUs and part
of your model runs really,
really well on Cloud TPU, you
can create your owness tare
own esoteri
heterogeneous cluster and test
the model to the right parts of
the cluster run on the right
compute nodes.
But UW    one thing we've
learned at Google is as you push
the boundaries of computational
power, as you push extreme
scale, you need to optimize the
entire system from end to end.
And what I mean is, you need
to take into account not just
the amount of discs that you use
to feed your data quickly into
the excelling
accelerate or pods and not just
the network that connects all of
these distribute ed machines
together, but you also need a
highly-tuned software platform,
and to tell you about that, I'd
like to tell you about some of
the latest changes that are
happening, that are still under
act    active development in C
ore TensorFlow.
presentation, we had a picture
of the Core TensorFlow Platform,
and I've redrawn that add
adding a few extra boxes.  I'm
going to talk to you today about
XLA, Estimate ors, and datasets
. start with closest to the bare
med     metal, let's talk about
XLA.  TensorFlow is designed to
go from research to production,
and production means not just
serve ers in a data center, but
it means going all the way from
phones to these exotic hardware
compute devices like pup     TPU
s. in order to run efficiently
and to get the extreme
performance, you need a highly
tuned software stack      stack.
As it turns out, in order to
get the optimize ed code, you
need to bring your own compile
er.  XLA is tensor
TensorFlow's compile er.  XLA
stands for Accelerate ed
ak Accelerate ed Linear
Algebra.  And when you use it
you design yourgraph, and XLA
will take a subset or even a
whole grap and run a huge number
of opt immigration passes over
it,                 pass
optimization
passes over it and approximately
put the machine
to run on what you have.
We're taking the algorithm
that does extreme performance on
image recognition and XLA will
take a subset of that graph and
it will reorder the computations
and krowt put the
output the assembly in binary
form to run efficiently on CP
CPUs or GPUs.
But XLA was designed for the
Explosion in exotic hardware
that we see in machine learning
learning.  XLA has a
plug     pluggable back end so
that you can target your own
hardware elements.
TPUs are just a custom backe
nd for XLA.  In doing so we take
advantage of the optimizations
that we do for CPUs and GPUs and
we're able to run them also on
TPUs.
But XLA runs sort of
underneath the hood and so it's
sometimes a little hard to see,
so if you'd like to see XLA in
action, you can turn on trace
ing when you run your TensorFlow
computation, and if you print
out the trace information that's
stored in that run metadata
object, you might see something
like this.n one of the node stat
s we see this funny underscore X
LA launch operation.  If you're
not using XLA, the node stats
will be your TensorFlow graph
nodes, but what happens when you
use XLA is the XLA compile er
generates that optimize ed
binary, and the XLA launch
operation is the time spent
actually running that bieb ree
on             binary on your
compute devices. one thing
that's interesting is the node
names don't correspond,
necessarily, with your
TensorFlow graph, and the reason
for that is that XLA preforms
whole program optimization.
If you've ever used an
optimize ing compile er and look
ed at the assembly that's output
afterwards, you notice that it
doesn't necessarily match up
with your statements that you
write in, for example, C.
That's because the optimize and
compile er is doing a number of
tricks underneath the hood to
get optimal machine performance,
and XLA is doing that not just
at the function or the operation
level, but it's schedule ing
whole programs to run
efficiently.
So, we've talked about XLA or
how you run on these new
hardware platforms all the way
across the range of devices we
support, but I now want to talk
about how you actually write
your algorithms so that they can
run across all of these
platforms, and for that we have
Estimate ors.
Now, this code I'm showing
you is copy and paste ed directl
y from our source repository,
and it runs today on C  CPUs and
GPU, and I'm going to show you
how you can modify it to run on
TPUs.
When you use Estimate ors,
you define your machine learning
algorithm using a model
function, and this is the model
definition for a simple
convolutional neural network to
recognize handwritten digits,
this is the M (?) dataset for
those of you that are familiar.
I want to draw your attention
to the final three lines, in
order to see them a a little
better, we've made them a little
bigger.
Normally, when you train your
machine learning algorithm, you
use a grade       gradient
descent optimize er or similar
to optimize the weights.  This
is the training step of your
machine learning algorithm.  In
order to get it to run on TPUs,
you just wrap your gradient
descent optimize er with a TPU
cross-shard optimize er.  TPUs
have a number of parallel
compute elements that all work
together, and in order to
aggregate the learned weights,
you need to use this cross-
cross-shard optimize er to
relearn the entire algorithm.
That is the only change
required when you're using
Estimate ors to run on CPU, GPUs
and TPUs for this example.
Now, how do you actually run it?
You've got to define your main
function.  Using Estimate ors
it's very simple.
Normally you just design
define the Estimate ors
based on the model function and
you call train.  Tolgt this to
To get this to
work on TPUs you use a TPU E
stimate or and a TPU Run Config.
A that's it.  Those are all
the changes required for this
model to work on CPU, GPUs, and
TPUs.
Some more complicate ed
models may require additional
code changes, but the TensorFlow
Team is constantly working to
reduce the amount of code
changes required as you go all
the way to production on all of
these different platforms.
If you'd like to hear more
about the high-level API, I
encourage you to check out the
talk in the next hour about
TensorFlow with the high-level
APIs.
So, we've talked about how to
define your machine learning
algorithms, we've talked about
how they execute on hardware
device, but we're missing one
key thing.  The machine learning
triad that has relate ed in a
Explosion of progress has been
fueled by three components, high
-      high-performance
computation, advances in
algorithms, and also input data.
Without input data, all the
fancy acceleration you want is
not going to generate any more
than random numbers.
Cloud TPUs are designed to
int dprait with the rest
integrate
with the rest of Google platform
to make it easy to load data in
a high-      high-performance
way.  You can load data from
your persistent disc or your
ephemeral loyal SSD on Google
Compute Engine, but you can also
stream data in directly from
Google Cloud storage into your
Cloud TPUs, and for those of you
doing advance ed reinforcement
algorithms or other sorts of
things, you can run simulate ors
on Google  Compute Engine and
integrate that with your machine
learn      learning model
running on your Cloud TPUs.
But as it turns out, we at
Google, we've been deploy
deploying these high opinion hfa
nce                     high
performance accelerate ors of CP
Us and G  GPUs for a while, and
we find when you put them into
production you find new bottle
neck, I think this is best
explained with an example of if
.  If you optimize ed your
software platform, you use
techniques to overlap
competition,              comp
computation, and that's what
we've done here, for this image
model we run input on the CPU
for the next training step while
our accelerate or is running
the model and learning on the
current training step.
But if you all of a sudden
just take this and put this over
to an Accelerate or that's 10
times faster, your training step
time is not going to decrease
anywhere close to what you would
hope.
To help you feed data in in a
flexible but high-
high-performance manner, we're
introduce ing a new API in
TensorFlow 1.2 called Datasets.
TensorFlow 1.2, the first
release candidate is coming out
as we speak, and we encourage
you all to try out these new API
s, kick the tires      tires.
Although, they're still a work
in progress, we think they're
very excite ing, and I'd like to
show you a little about what
the status of the API looks like
. a code snipbit where we load a
set of data from a TF record on
file.  We then repeat the
dataset as we train our
algorithm.  We perform some
parse ing and disportion
distortions to this
using the parse er function, but
we can use this in parallel
using the parallel num threads
through a parallel map.
Finally we batch it up into
training bunches that he with
then feed to the accelerate or.
This new datasets API borrows
from functional programming and
other advance ed concepts to
make it easy to define high-p
erformance input pipelines that
run well.We've talked about now
XLA, Estimate ors and Dataset,
and these are just some of the
new changes coming in TensorFlow
1.2 that helped make these high
-performance accelerate ors be
they CPUs, GPUs or TPUs really
sing.
Now, on top of this base of
awesome compute and
infrastructure, we see some
really phenomenal learning and
research work, and for that I'd
like to turn it back over to Zak
Stone to talk about research on
the frontier.
>> ZAK STONE: Thanks,
Brennan.  We've witnessed e
xtraordinary breakthroughs in
machine learning research over
the passed several years, and
while there are many typeses of
machine learning, many of these
breakthroughs vs. been
concentrate ed at the edges of
what's computational
computationally
possible, and we believe that
much large er amounts of
computation are going to unlock
new discovery ies and new breakt
hroughs, which with large er and
more complex models than
researchers can practically
experiment with today. the photo
behind me, we'll       it
represents the research learning
community.  The mountain
represents the break
breakthroughs yet to be
discovered, and that gate is the
computational limits that are h
oaltding researchers back
research
holding researchers back
.
Our goal is to break open the
gate and help research
researchers to climb that mown
mountain to find new
discovery.  I'm thrilled the
TensorFlow Research Cloud was
announce ed yesterday in order
to support open machine learning
research worldwide and help
rrch      researchers who
currently don't have enough
access to computation experiment
with large er and more complex
motion is denied else.
come
models.e've dedicate ed a
thousand of these new Cloud TPUs
to accelerate open machine
learning research.  We're going
to set up an application process
to let people from all
backgrounds and all fields of
expertise propose projects to
take advantage of this extra
amount of computing power.  This
is 1le 0peta  a          80peta
frop      aflops all together
and we can't wait to see what
beam are going to do with
people are
going to do.  What could they be
?  We can't wait to find out.
example that was mentioned
yesterday.  I want to mention A
uto ML it's a family of
techniques for using machine
learning models to develop new
machine learning models.  I
won't go through the details
here, but these are just two
examples from a linguistic
problem and an image recognition
problem where we've used the
machine learning          learn
ing model to generate the
architectures that you see here
on the screen, and the
interesting thing about it is
that both of these models look
kind of complex and organic.
They don't necessarily look like
the thing that a mathematician
might have come up with by hand.
Now, this kind of
experimentation requires immense
amounts of compute, but
fortunately, with this step
function to Cloud TPUs and
eventually to the TPU Pods we
want to shift the research minds
et from scares tee to abundance
so you can start contemplate ing
these kind of techniques to
search for new model
architectures and open up new
applications.
So just to be clear, we have
one underlie  ying product in
fool      Google Cloud which is
the new Cloud TPUs on the Google
Compute Engine, but we're offer
ing the community access to them
in two ways.or general use,
we're setting up a Cloud TPU
alpha program that lets
businesses, startup, individuals
, students, people, artists,
anyone who is interested in this
frontier of machine learning,
to sign up and try to get early
access to these limited numbers
of Cloud TPUs to figure out how
to adapt them for their
applications.
But for those of you out
there who are doing cutting edge
machine learning research, who
are extending this frontier,
we've set up the TensorFlow
Research Cloud, and we're going
to open up this application
process to invite you in to take
advantage of these thousand
Cloud TPUs to do things that
just aren't feasible today.
If you're interested in
either of these programs, we
encourage you to sign up now at
g.co/TPUsignup, and tell us more
about your compute needs and
we'll notify you as soon as more
information is available about
Cloud TPUs and the TensorFlow
Research Cloud.
Before I go, I'd like to
encourage you to either stick
around for the next session,
which will cover TensorFlow for
non-experts and tell you more
about the high     high-level
APIs that we described early
ier, or join us in the office
hours section for office hour,
and if you're worried, how do I
choose between the next session
and office hours?  Don't worry.
We've added a next office hour
after the next session so you
can do both.
Thanks again to your
attention, we'll really excite
ed about TensorFlow and Cloud
TPUs and we look forward to
speaking you with in office hour
s.(Applause).
10:30 a.m.
May 18, 2017
.
Google
UI
I/O
.
Fragment Tricks
-
s-
May 18, 2017. I/O.
Fragment
tricks        T
ricks
.
Stage 3
welcome to tragment tricks,
tricks today we're going
to talk about a few ective ways
to iewts frag            use
fragment patterns in your apps.
Some of these may seem a little
bay     basic, but they're also
things that are going to help
you factor things effectively,
and makes sure you can keep your
code clean.
Stupid trag      fragment
tricks.
>> Yeah. Stupid fragment
Now, let's start with a
little history behind this,
which kind of helps understand
where some of the Fragment APIs
came from, so as we started move
ing into large-screen devices
in the honeycomb era, we started
to realize a few specific
patterns in the way that some
apps are put together,
especially app
s of the time.
You've got one area
denoted         devote ed to
your navigation and another area
denoted to content.  When you
put these two things together,
you can imagine on a small
screen device, you might see the
navigation as one screen that
advances to a content screen,
and when you're on a large er
screen device       device,
you're able to show the same t
hings side-by-side.We had a
question of how do I write an
app that works seamlessly across
both?
So the Fragment APIs were
born.  It was something that you
could use to factor out your
activity components into two
separate pieces that you could
show differently based on
different device cop figure
racial
configurations.
This works really well for
some applications like g  gmail,
but you're probably not using
that if you followed the
development of app design over
the past several years, you
notice that this sort of pattern
doesn't fit for a lot of
things.
However, it's still extremely
useful for representing your
application as a series of
destinations, so even on a
small-screen device, you might
have an app that looks
like            looks something
like this.  We've got our little
application where we can order
some microkitchen snacks
snacks around the Google campus,
and for each one of these
screens, you can perform a
replace transactions for replace
the destination that you were
looking at previously with the
new one.  A replace transaction
will remove any fragment in the
container and then add the new
fragment., the nice thing about
this is you can place these
particular transactions on to
the backstack, we'll handle the
back navigation for you.  Now,
the nice thing about this is
that the content and navigation
pane separation isn't limited to
just large screens.  This can
really help to keep your Chrome
stable in your application.  So
any time you have things like
bars, net drawers, bottom
navigation bars, any of these
things that you want to keep
stable and perform some
consistent animations from one
screen to another, this really
lets you do it in a way that is
really difficult to being a
publish with activity-to-
activity-to-activity
transitions
transitions where you can't have
the continuity as you navigate
deeper in your app's hierarchy.
Now, let's talk
>> Now, let's talk a little
about navigation flows.  When I
talk about navigation flow, I'm
talking about those step-by-step
throw       flows that you have
in your application.  So when y
ou have a checkout or a sign up,
or a setup wizard, you're going
to go -- the users are going to
go step by step through the
navigation, and then they may
want to wonder back using the
back button and then go forward
again      again.  Then when
they're all done, you want to be
all done with that.  You want t
he user to be able to go back
through the checkout process
again with the back button, you
wouldn't want that, that would
kind of suck. going to focus on
our app, the microkitchen app
which we've been trying to sell
to the Google ers to sell the
free micro       microkitchen
apps. >> It hasn't been
working very well.
>> It has not. We have new
customers coming this summer,
intern, so we're pretty sure
they will partake in our great
free microkitchen service.  And
when the user comes in, they're
going to chick on          click
on the Cart Button, and what
we're going to do is remove the
little Cart at the bottom, the
little fragment there, and then
we're also going to remove that
big -- replace that big fragment
at the top with our new
fragment that we're going to
label,  Cart.  Not the fragment,
but we're going to label the
state      state, Cart.I'm going
to talk about that a little bit
later, why we're giving it a
name on the backstack.  And then
when they hit checkout, they
can then choose the address they
want to ship to, and we're just
going to replace that fragment
with their address selection
one, and they can choose payment
then, and we replace again with
with a faiment fragment,
fragment, and again we
add it to the backstack and we
don't need a name for the backs
tack, but we'll talk about it in
a little bit, but they can go
back through the back it is
stack, navigate back and choose
a different address if they want
by hitting the back button.
As developers, we don't have
to do any other work.  Backstack
just pops that fragment right
back into our state      state,
and it's great.  And then the
user can go back through, choose
a payment, and then confirm t
heir purchase.
Now, here on the Confirm P
urchase screen, we're going to
do a couple of things all at
once.  We're going to do a pop
back stack all the way back to
that original Cart state that we
said, and because we passed the
inclusive flag there, now it
pops -- that Cart state also,
and it will go all the way back,
pop all the states back, and
then statement           at the
same time, we add this new
transaction that will replace
that state with our thank you
page because we want to thank
them for giving us all their mon
ey.  It's pretty good.  We need
to thank them for giving us all
their money.
Now, on this one, we have a
little different thing going on.
The Okay Button doesn't just
create        create a new
transaction, it's going to pop
the backstack as well.  Now, no
matter what the user does, the
user is going to do the right
thing.  They're not going to add
a new transaction -- add to
that state.  We don't want to
have that thank you page come
back again if they pop the
backstack. , so it's going to
come right back to where they
can buy more stuff from us., can
you see some of the keys here
to backstack management.  Always
maintain your backstack going
forward.  It's so much easy ier
to manage your backstack if you
choose the direction your user
is going to go on the back stack
as you navigate forward.
At the time the user presses
the back button, don't at the
time choose what they're going
to do.  That's a lot harder to
manage.
So, to take advantage of this
kind of thing, sometimes you
need to do some synthetic back
stack management, that means if
you have a   an exearn ital link
it              an
external link into your
application, a deep-nested thing
, they're selecting a particular
Cart button, and when they hit
the back button, you don't want
them to go to the main screen.
You want them to go into the
category, perhaps, or even from
a               .Or even from a
notification.
>> That's a great example.
From notification.  Or maybe in
search, in the application, you
might want to have the same
thing.
So what do we do?  Well, we
just execute a whole bunch of
transactions all at the same
time.  Just build up the stack
for them, boo     boom, boom,
boom, boom, and execute them.
>> ADAM POWELL: Hang on,
George.  If I can make repeated
transactions that means on each
of those transactions I'm going
to start and stop those fragment
s as I execute each one in turn,
so that can be really
expensive          expensive,
right.  So how do I go ahead and
main      maintain the back
stack state without doing a lot
of heavy-weight work as I start
and top the fragments along the
way.That's a really big problem.
You have to create the view,
tear them down again, inflation,
right.  It seems like a lot of
unnecessary work.  It is a lot
of unnecessary work.  Sorry,
guys.You want to fix that?
>> ADAM POWELL: Sure.
>> GEORGE MOUNT: All right.
Thanks, Adam.  So now we have
this new thing here called set
resoredding ol loud.
sored        reorderring
allowed.  What it does is allows
all of the execution to happen
all at once without change ing
your fragment state.  And then
at the very end, we bring up all
the fragments that need to be
brought up and tear down all the
frag      fragments that need
to be torn down, and now your
fragments don't have to go
through all of that oh, I got
added, I got removed, I got
added, I got removed, so we can
optimize this for you.ut you
have to watch out because if you
expected a fragment to exist
that didn't -- that might have
been optimize ed out, if you
expected it to go through this
creation, it might not have done
that, so you have to watch out
for this.  So you use this in
your applications.  It's great
to use, but expect some slightly
different behavior than before
., you might have seen in our
application that as a user
clicks through the checkout
screen, it was just pop, pop,
pop, pop.  The screens changed
instantaneously, and that's not
very pleasant, so what we can do
is we can add transitions.he
easiest ones to use are the basi
c transitions that come with
fragment, and there are three
options, and this is done on the
transactions, you call a step
you call a set
transition.  And the basic
transitions are fade, open, and
close.And from this, it's really
hard to see the difference
differences, but you
can see the fade has just a
simple cross fade, and then the
open and close also have a fade
and zoom, so play with it a
little bit, see what works well
in your application and see what
you look best. provides a nice
subtle effect for your
transitions
transitions.
>> ADAM POWELL: What if you
want to do something a little
bit more in keeping with my own
apps design.
>> GEORGE MOUNT: Yeah, if
you want something a little more
custom, then we can use
animations.  Animations in this
case is the view animations that
allow you to change scale, rot
ation,
translation, alpha, so fade ing.
So you can set those for --
this is only on the support
library, you can set those on
the view coming in, the fragment
coming in, on a separate one
for the fragment being popped --
or I'm sorry being removed, and
also the same things for the
pop as well, the ones that are
being added and removed, so you
can have different animations
for each of those.  And you can
get them like this, which is
very nice, a slide effect, which
you couldn't do with the basic
animations, with the basic
transitions.
Now, if you're working with
the framework fragments you can
do the same thing with animate
ers, but they provide even more
benefit because now you can
animate any property on the view
.  That means you can have some
really custom animations,
whatever you want to do.  It's
great.
And what's better, is now you
can also do that in the
Support Like    library.
(Applause).
added for the framework so that
you can do this and set your
animations or animateors fl a
style.  Now, a lot of you have
been using the activity
transition, and you want to have
that work with fragments as
well, so activity transitions
a.m.
transitions allows this great
ability to have a shared element
change from one view to another
, so in this case from one
fragment to another, and it
works on activity transitions
from lobbypop on.
lobby       lob lolly
transitions
from lollypop on, it's very usef
ul.
We added the ability to do t
hat.  So for fragment, instead
of doing this on the transition,
you do this on the fragment
itself.  You can set the views
-- you can set the transition to
do on the views that are coming
in, and this is for all the
views that are not the shared
element, so that's the Enter T
ransition.
And the Shared Element Enter
Transition, this is the one you
do on the view that is move ing.
This is our shared element, in
this case I don't know what it
was.  The almond       almonds
maybe.  And here this is a
combination of change bounds,
change transform, and change
image trans       transform, too
many things to fit on the slide
, but that's what it is here.
And then in the transaction,
we add the shared element
itself.  And the shared element
is the view that's in that fr
agment, and then we have a
target name.  This name, this is
a shared element transition
name, and this is a name that
you've given the transition
element in the fragment that has
not been inflated yet, so in
this case, it's in the My
Fragment that's being pulled in.
And then question have our
transition, which is great
great.  But something's wrong.
What?  Can you see it?veryone
raise your hand if you can see
it.  What's the problem with
this?  Okay.  A lot of you can
see the problem.  All right.
Transition is only working one
way.  Right.  It works great
getting into the detail view,
but when we come back to that
main view with all of those
other elements, you're not
seeing it, and why is that?
Well, that main view is a
recycle er view, and what's
happening is the recycle er view
will layout its views after the
set adapter call is made.  So
if you wait for the layout call
after this adapter call is made,
and the transition is coming in
and saying, hey I want to up
the share, and it's not there.
So what does it do?  It says oh,
give up, fade out.
So in activity transition,
what do we do?  Well, it's
great, we have a thing called
postpone ing the transition.  So
postpone enter transition, and
when the views are ready, we
call start postpone edentert
ransition.  It gives you the
ability to wait for view, come
on view, come on views, (
(whistle ing) and when they're
all ready, then you say, go!
So we want to do this for
fragments as well.  So here we
go.  We can do it for fragments
fragments, but there
is one extra thing you need to
do.  You absolutely have to have
the set reordering allowed
because for our short time while
you're postpone ing, both
fragmentses are there.  They're
both act
fragments
are there, they're both active,
and that's not what you expect,
you expected one to move and
the other to be added.  So both
views for both fragment
fragments are in the create ed
state, so that's going to be a
little weird for you.        ,
so we want to make sure you know
you're getting into this
situation.
So let's see how it's done in
our application.  In my view,
now you can do this any time
before the Oncreate view
view.  If you want to do a non-c
reate, whatever you want to do.
You call postponeenter Tran
sition because I know at this
point, I'm going to do a
recycle er view, and I know I
need to worry about the
transitions there.
And because I love data bindi
ng, some you have might know
that, I love data binding, and
we have a few others here too.
That's good too, thank you Adam,
if you haven't seen that talk,
you should go back and watch it.
We're using that.
So here I'm sitting
setting the adapter for the
recycle er view     view.  Now
I'm setting the adapter and now
I have to wait for the layout.
So I'm waiting for the layout,
and then the listener, I call
startpostponedentertransition.
Now my transition is ready and
it will just go on ahead and --
I think I skipped a slide.
(Laughing).
Okay.  So it works.
>> ADAM POWELL: All right.
So one of the other features --
move ing along to something
completely different.  One of
the other features we get a lot
of questions are the start
retain instance method on
fragments, you remain
retain an instance across
activity, deconstruction, and
creation, cause something like a
configuration change.
So, this means that the
object instance itself of the
fragment that you've marked this
way is transferred across the
parent recreation, so anything
that you put there is moved
along with it, so full object,
you don't have to serialize this
into a parcellable or across or
safe instance state.he
important thing to remember if
you're doing this is this
doesn't happen if the process is
recreate ed.  Your objects
aren't there, be so you need to
be a little careful about this.
You need to make sure you can
still restore from instant state
if you have to, even though in
the common case you may still
have the full objects that you
may have create ed in the first
place. this is a replacements
for the old on retain
nonconfiguration instance method
that was on activity, in fact,
this same mechanism is used to
implement the fragment
fragments version of this, but
what's a little more interesting
is that this mechanism is right
now the back     backbone of
the new view model component
that we've been talking about
early ier here, so the view
models are actually saved within
a retain instance fragment to s
huffle them across from one acti
vity to the next.
And this just kind of goes to
show the types of
infrastructure you can build on
top of a retain instance
fragment, it's something a
little bit more on the abstract
end of things, so we end up
getting questions about hey,
what's this good for, and well
this is a pretty good example.
Just like we talked about
with view models, it means that
there is a few things that you
really need to avoid.  In this
case, don't put views in or
retain instance fragment unless
you want to do a lot of manual b
ookkeeping.  Technically you can
kind of get away with it if
you're really careful, but make
sure you release all of your
references and on destroy view
of that particular fragment, so
on and so forth, but really it
ends up being best to just kind
of avoid it.  We'll do a few
more patterns later in the talk
here on what you can do instead.
Context, specifically
activity contexts.  We all know
why you don't want to stave
save an instance of the
activity longer than the lifet
ime of that activity itself, but
the thing that really tends to
catch people is call-back
reference, so if you register a
listener or some kind of call-
back with a fragment and that is
going to outlive the container,
it's really easy to accidently
close over that context that you
had and have the activity still
outlast the original host.So
child fragments are something
that hit a lot of people hard a
few years ago, because frankly,
we had a lot of bugs around
them.  They were create ed to
solve a pick problem, and that
was dependency management within
a particular activity.So, co
nsider this case.  You get a
fragment that has a view page
er, pretty common, right.  The
viewpage er uses a fragment page
er adapter because that's a
pretty easy way to use a viewp
age er, and then you remove the
page er fragment.  Now we have a
problem.
So, what actually happens in
that case?  You've got all the
fragments added by the page er
adapter, but the host fragment
or conceptual host fragment that
has the viewpage er itself was
removed, and now something has
to be in charge of remove ing
the individual page fragments,
and this was something that
really kind of meant to show
that a single collection of
fragments is insufficient. fact,
when the Fragment APIs were
first rolling out for a lot of
internal developers around
honeycomb this is one of the
first questions that we got, and
it took us quite a while to
come back and address this.  Of
what happens when you do have
dependencies in between fragment
s?
And part of the reason why
this was such a pain is because
we didn't have any ordering
guarantees around fragments
being createssed, and
creates
create ed, and what's worse is a
lot of times this would only
come up much, much later in the
process.
Just because you added
fragments in one particular
order, you can control that
order as you're running that and
kind of running the initial
transactions that build up that
state, but when your process die
, and we restore that fragments
from instant state later, the
order of that recreation is
always undefined, depending on
what all may have happened
throughout the lifetime of your
activity before, just kind of do
some artifacts of internal book
keep         bookkeeping, this
was something that could cause
these things to be reordered in
terms of which one would get on
create first and so on and so
forth and it made it difficult
to connect any sort of shared
state.
The sort of shared state is
easy ier to handle with the view
model system that we showed
early ier, but at the time we
really didn't have a good
solution to this problem.
So, one of the other things
that was kind of a pain is the
deferred transaction commits
that have been common ever since
-- or up until we added the C
ommit Now method on method
transaction, the nice thing and
the     and the reason it was
done in the first place is to
avoid re-enterrant calls.  You
didn't have to worry about one
particular transaction being
half executed and then starting
starting another
transaction as a result of it.
But this really did have a
cost, and I think that if you're
in this room right now, you've
probably experience ed some of
the costs of this.  Raise your
hand if you called execute pendi
ng transactions to fix a bug?
Yeah.  That's a lot of hands.
So, this is one of those
things that ends up being really
kind of difficult to work with.
So, child fragment dependency
ies work out really well
because they solve a lot of
these particular issues.  It's a
separate fragment manager so
you don't get the re-enterrant
cases no matter what.  If you go
ahead and use commit now on a
bunch of these things, you don't
have to worry about your parent
being in a potentially
inconsistent state as you're
doing this because you're all
working within your own local
unit.
All of these things are added
and removed as a unit, which
means it solves the viewpage er
problem.  It means if you remove
the container
containing fragment you don't
have to care about the
implementation details of the
fragment.  This kind of seems
like one of those duh things in
behind        behindsight,
behind
hindsight           hindsight
and it's guaranteed to be
restored.  This is super
important because now you can
rely on when things are actually
restored. don't have to worry
about these ordering things that
are out of your control.
But perhaps most importantly,
the implementation details,
again, don't leak into your
surrounding containers
containers.  So, in
conclusion, many of you may have
run into a lot of particular
issues around child fragments.
Please go and try version 26.
We have fixed more and more
issues around this, speferl
specifically around
inflate ing child fragments.his
is one of my favorite uses of
this.  We talked early ier about
using fragments as very course-
grained applications within your
destination, something that
takes up an entire UI pane of
your app, but nesting within
other fragments, even if you
inflate them from one of these
course er grained navigation
destination, it just kind of
works, like you don't have to
worry about taking care of all
these other sort of lifecycle
issues, and it lets you build
smarter and encapsulate ed
components.
We always get this question,
too.  Hey, do I build a V group
or a fragment?  And there is a
lot of ink spilled and keyboards
smashed making these particular
arguments           arguments
online.I never know what to do
with this, building a V group or
fragment, I always tell people,
just use V groups.
>> ADAM POWELL: Exactly so,
you know, excuse me, you said
the cross on the streams was bad
, but so for this it's
essentially as follows for the
rule of thumb.  Views should
only be responsible for
displaying information and
publishing direct user
interaction events.  These end
up being very low-level events,
button was schikd or    clicked
or user scrolled something, or
responsible for drawing text or
other parts that are user
interaction.
Whereas fragments integrate
with the surrounding life
lifecycle and may be aware of
other app components.  This is
really what gives context to
everything you're doing in your
UI, you mind bind to a service,
you might communicate to the
data model, performing a
database query, so on and so
forth.
So, you should never use a
fragment when a view will do,
but you also want to make sure
you're not adding outside
dependency ies to your views.
That's definitely the code
smell, if you ever find yourself
doing something like trying to
bind to a service from a view
implementation or trying to make
a network call, or again,
trying to integrate with
anything that's outside of the
realm of just that one
individual view.
But that means that there is
a hole.  It means that you can't
build just something that's
simple as like a completely
self-contained "like" button
that you can stick in the middle
of one of your layouts and
treat it and forget.  Give it
some parameters and go.
Well, this is one of the r
easons why you can inflate
fragments.  In this case, we're
showing that you can define
parameters to these that you can
place in line.  We can go ahead
and inflate arguments in a way
that -- excuse me -- in a way
that allows you to do this
without having a lot of very
heavy weight integration.  You
don't have to go and find it,
configure it separately.  You
can just do it in line.
So one of the things that
made this really difficult to do
in the past was kind of, again,
just artifact of history in
that you couldn't actually set
fragment argument
arguments           argument
arguments, that
arguments bundle, after the
fragment had been added to a
fragment manager, so now we've
relaxed that and we've said that
now fragment arguments can be
change ed any time the state
isn't saved, include ing during
inflation, so there is a case
where after you rotate or so on
and so forth, and we're
reconnecting inflated fragments,
which is again something that
we do automatically, then you
can run into this case where
we've already restored that
fragment, we're trying to hook i
t back up again, but it's
already added, which means that
you can't do what the natural
thing is, which is to represent
all of those arguments that you
may inflate as arguments in the
bundle, so that way you have,
basically, a single source of
truth for all of the
configuration parameters of that
fragment.
Well, now you can.ait a
second here.  Go back.  This is
not a state safe thing
--
>> ADAM POWELL: Oh, yeah, so
I don't know where this comes
from, but people apparently try
to commit transactions when the
state is already saved.hy would
they do that?
>> ADAM POWELL: I don't know
.  Because they can't tell.
That might have been yet, yeah,
so we added a simple Git around
this so you know when it happens
, and it makes write ing lifec
ycle components that makes sure
that you don't try to commit
fragment transactions when it's
not valid to do so.  There is
It's a whole electroof
a            heck of a lot easy
ier.  Thank you..
So again, part of what we're
trying to do here is create a
much better layered
infrastructure.  We've
traditionally hidden a lot of
these internals in some of these
Android components such that
only the internal components are
twittle ing them, which means
as soon as you all have a more
complicate ed case you're trying
to handle, we've made it very
difficult for you to do this in
the past     past, so we tried
to open a lot more of those
things up, make these a little
easy ier to inspect from your
own code and deal with the cases
that arrived         arise that
we didn't think of.So, in this
case, the pattern that we really
kind of want to encourage is
mapping fragment arguments to
attributes for those UI fragment
s.  Again, this gives you kind
of a single source of truth
truth.
So let's tb ahead and go
go ahead to an example
of this.  In this scais,
case,       this case,
we have a few column-base the
extensions that make this a
little easy ier to handle.  In
this case, we have one utility
method that is just with styled
attributes here, so many of you
have dealt with inflate ing
attributes to views, and you
know, you have to get it typed
away, recycle it afterwards, and
it's easy to wrap these up
inside some extension functions,
similarly, we have this simple
little thing.  Hey, is there a
bundle there for arguments
already, if so, reuse it,
otherwise, create a new one.
So, these are the sorts of
things that it really adds to
the Fragment API, all of the
kind of things that are kind of
a pain in the neck to do with
fragment, you can make some
simple extensions that were
really hard to do before, but
for example, one of my favorite
features for something like this
is to use property delegates to
deal with argument, and you can
wrap even more of this stuff
and just basically treat them as
normal property ies on your
fragment objects.So, putting a
bunch of this together, fragment
s help you maintain more of a
content and Chrome separation.
Give you the ainlt       ability
to keep your content pages as
fully encapsulate ed items
without disturbing the rest of
the UI around it.  You get rich
er transitions.  You bet better
shared components because you
can reuse a lot of thee things
and you don't have to reinitial
lies them all of them separately
and you can better encapsulate
your dependency, so you don't
necessarily have to leak all of
these things to the surrounding
host.
And, thank you very much for com
ing.  Anyone who has questions,
be please come to one of the
mics up in the center aisles and
we'll be glad to take them.
(Applause).
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Hello.
Thank you for the great talk.
So, my question is about the
first part of the presentation,
like for example,
the page where you talked about
manage ing the best take, so to
be honest, I have not been
using fragments a lot, and
recently, and I am doing the
same thing with activities, you
know, manage ing the back stack
and so you can compare a little
bit these two approaches?  Why
should we use fragments for that
now but not just others.king
sure you have any persistent
Chrome is obviously one item of
it.  But one of the other things
that is convenient when you use
fragments so this is the
ability to pop several layers of
the stack at once.  We were
able to pop the entirety of the
checkoutflow as one single unit
rather than having to, say,
return are a result to eek prior
fragment to say, yep, I'm
finished and you should finish t
oo, yep, I'm finished and you
should too, and it makes it
easy ier to handle those sort of
cases.  Anything you want to
add to that.
>> GEORGE MOUNT: Resources
when you're dealing with just a
single activity, because when
you have multiple activities
they're all in the -- all in
memory while you're going 24R50U
your             through your
whole application.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Thank
you.You're welcome.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Hi, . I
would like to ask about the
fragment transactions, so do you
guys have plans to use replace
fragment instead of add
fragments?  Because the problem
is, like sometimes I find out --
I mean, is this just similar --
I mean, the behavior is
different, right, but the
problem is when you do the pop
stack of the fragments, there is
no good way to actually figure
like when you try to update a
toolbar or action bar.  So I
just wonder, like, what's the --
what's the recommendation in
terms of like manage ing when
you pop up the stack from the
fragment manager, how to
maintain, like, the changes when
you pop out -- like the changes
with the toolbar
.ke, I start using more of the
replace fragment instead of like
add fragment mainly because of
that, so I wonder if you guys
have some recommendation on how
to handle the situation? >> ADAM
POWELL:  Yeah, I mean, if
you're using the    the -- if
you're using the options menu
from each of the fragments to
change some of the options items
in the tool     toolbar, some
of that is kind of handle ed
automatically for you.  I
believe there is still a API to
change a title within the
transaction itself, so you can
-- this is how we implemented
some of the fragment breadcrumbs
widget, that I think is still
available in the source
repository if you want to refer
to to in terms of change ing
things like the title, but in c
ases like that, it's basically
what you can do is you can
listen to the -- you can add a
back stack change listener to
the fragment list itself.  You
get a call back any time the
back stack changes.  Of you can
go and inspect the top-most
element of the back stack and
make some changes based on that.
Alternatively, you can have
the fragment publish a
particular event either using --
by change ing a shared view
model, for example, to change a
title or something as it starts
versus stops.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Okay.
Yeah.  Thanks.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: So the
child fragment manager has a
back stack of its own currently,
but by default it doesn't do
anything when you press the back
button.  Have you given any
thought of what you can do with
the back stack there or what
you're supporting in terms of
the back stack?I could not have
planted another question and
this is another thing this
escape ed our slides.  We went
ahead and added a new method,
should be in V26 called set
primary navigation fragment, and
what that does is it's
something, you can actually
also fetch it back out
but it will debt gait things
like the back button down to a
child fragment and that will
train all the Charlie deep, so
as beep as you may want to go
with that, then that attempt to
pop the back stack will
propagate all the way down and
it won't be until the bottom-m
ost fragment has nothing else to
pop that the parent will be
handle ing the pop operation.
You'd         Awd     Thanks.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Thank
you so much for the amazing
talk.  I did have a question
about child fragments, so in my
previous attempt I tried to
inflate a map fragment inside a
fragment, and it added it to the
fragment manager of the parent
fragment.
>> ADAM POWELL: So, there is
-- when was previously
previously, I'm curious
?Previously was about three
weeks ago.Three weeks ago?
There are two fragment managers
that a fragment has.  One is its
own fragment manager and one is
the child frag am manager.
There is a Git fragment manager
and Git child fragment manager,
so depending what you're looking
to do.ut if you use the load --
if you use the on create view
method then any fragment tags
that that creates should be
added to the child fragment m
anager, if you've come across a
case where that's not happening,
please see me after because we
want to fix it.
>> GEORGE MOUNT: We will be
in the sandbox, if we don't get
to questions, we'll be in the
sandbox in Building C.  Yeah.
Definitely.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Thanks
for an    an amazing talk,
first.  My question is more of a
best practice question.  I have
like this big fragment that
when a user pushes        pushes
a but the., inflates -- or you
get a transaction and you get a
child fragment in the middle of
the big practicing am
fragment and then
when the user pushes another
button, I replace the whole
thing to get like to a
subscreen.  Right?  And as soon
as I pop the subscreen I get
back to the main fragment, and
my question is, I'm not too sure
how the best practice is to
remove or prevent when popping
and coming from -- when pop
popping and coming back to
restore the child fragment I
just edit because, yeah, the
fragment -- the child fragment
manager automatically reinflight
inflates and puts the
small child fragment and I don't
want that, so what I do current
ly is on the view of my (?)
fragment, is I remove my child
fragments with (?) and I don't
know what to do there so I'm not
too sure how to prevent from
getting a new frag
fragment.
>> ADAM POWELL: Okay. I'm
trying to understand the case a
little beir      better.  So you
have your overall hosts either
at your activity or some similar
grandparent fragment.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Sleetly.
Yeah. >> ADAM POWELL: You're
remove ing a fragment within
that host.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Okay.
Inflate a small fragment in my
big one, right.  Let's say it's
just a view element or
something.
>> ADAM POWELL: Sure.ow I
change to another B fragment,
like okay, I replace the whole
thing and pop and come back, and
I don't want the small fragment
s to reappear         reappear,
and I'm not too sure how to
prevent the system from doing
that.
>> GEORGE MOUNT: I would say
during navigation, that's when
you would remove that fragment
from the child fragment manager,
right.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Exactly.
Yeah. can do that in
navigation when you're going out
.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Exactly,
but in that case usually I have
to use committal line
statements because the fragment
state is already statement,
right.If you ran on destroy, yes
.  I guess I'm a little curious
because it sounds like you
specifically don't want the
smaller fragment to survive.
You want it to be much more
ephemeral, essentially?
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: I want
it to die, basically, when I
leave the screen.kay.  I have to
say, I haven't run into that
case before.
(laughter).
>> GEORGE MOUNT: Maybe we
can think about it a little bit
and talk to you in the sandbox.
So what you may want to do is
you may want to remove that as
part of a separate transaction
that's not part of the back
stack as you navigate, but that
imply ies some knowledge of that
implementation detail, but it
sounds like you probably want to
avoid, but let's talk about
that a little deeper in the sand
box if possible.  Great.  Last
question?
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: So, I
was hope ing you could shed a
little light on something you
said in the beginning of the
talk.  You mentioned building up
the back stack when, let's say,
you went in from a deep blink,
but some of the U  UI gietd
guidelines say there is a
distinct difference between the
up navigation and the back but
the         button.  When is the
right time to actually generate
the back stack for the user?
Because right, we generally on
deep link the expected behavior
is the Up button should take you
up a level in your app, but the
back button should exit is what
I understood.
>> ADAM POWELL: To the
previous context.  You're
absolutely right.  This is a
wonderful question that I
couldn't have planted into the
audience again.  So yes, secialg
essentially, when you
start one of your activities on
the task of another application,
say when you click a view link
or web link where you're viewing
that content within your app,
then in those case ses you don't
want the synthetic back stack
yet. you want to do, is in that
case, the Up button is going to
jump you into your own task, so
in that case that's going to be
using the Start activity flags,
the flag activity new task, the
flag activity clear task, and
flag activity task on home.
Happy to write all of this down
for you in the sandbox if you're
interested, and then you want
to go ahead and as you jump into
that new activity you create
that synthetic back stack, so
that way that gets you deep into
the navigation of your
application, but back on your
own task.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Okay.
So the key is to key off of the
task.
>> GEORGE MOUNT: Yes,
exactly.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Awesome.
Thanks.
>> ADAM POWELL: Okay. I
think that's about all of the
time qeef we've got.
we've got.  We'll be in
the sandbox area if anyone else
wants to ask some questions, and
thank you very much.
(Applause).
(s
ession complete ed at
complete ed 11:10 a.m.
CS   )
>> Thank you for joining this
session, we will assist to go
through the registered exits to
make room for the next session.
If you rej     registered for
the next session in this room,
we ask that you please clear the
room and return to the
registration line outside.
Thank you.
(session complete ed at 11:10
a.m. Pacific)
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO  80132
800-825-5234
www.captionfirst.com
This text is being provided
in a realtime format.
Communication Access
Realtime Translation (CART) or
captioning are provided in
order to facilitate
communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally
verbatim record of the
proceedings.
***
.
ing Android Studio
May 18, 2017
San Jose, criminal
criminal
California
1230  :30 p.m.
Smith
Chromium   e
Good afternoon everyone.
Houmentd          How's it going
so far no   ?  Come on comment
on give me something.  There we
go.  Thank you so much for join
ing us.  My name is Dave Smith
.
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  I am
a log projects engineer.
DAVE SMITH:  We are hear to
talk to you today about how you
easy ily get started developing
for Android things use ing a
tool you probably already know
which is Android Studio.  So
let's talk a little bit about
Android things for a minute.  It
is an extension of the Android
platform to brand new form
factor in this case for embedded
in I/O thshgs         T.  This
is something
/O  oT.  This is something we
have done in the past.
>> LIZ ANDERSON: Destroyed
things is just yet another form
factor where we are bringing all
the power of the Android plat
plarm      form    form to this
new former   factor.  This is a
great things tore embedded in
IoT compefk         specifically
because it brings Android's
best-in-class tools to a space
that tra digsally nt        al
li       digs           digs
traditionally that hasn't
had well integrated tools ing.
They are separated.  There is
not real well integrated
experience in a who of
lot of case and that's what
makes Android things and    .
>> LIZ ANDERSON:
and Android
Studio so you a system.  You
can use these powerful tools to
develop debug and deploy your
applications to your devices for
development and then again in
to production.  Basically it
makes embedded development as
sem PIM         sill pelt
SIM Pell as
SIM Pell          simple very
many           vement has become
development
has become.  How many you are
Android developers in the room?
How many of you use Android
Studio roughly every day?  Okay.
Great.  So this is an awesome.
Because you guys already know
this tool.  And you know all of
the amazing things that can do
for you in terms of development
and deployment but just to give
you some background or some idea
here this means that now you
can use some of these amazing
Android sued      Studio feature
s that you are already familiar
instant run, UI layout blrs and
all of these great tools to
about       build applications
for erm     embedded devices.
You can leverage all the deep
integrations that are already in
Android Studio for Google
services.  Dep integrations for
things like Firebase as well as
the Google Cloud flat form
plarm       plat fofrl
Cloud
Platform.  You have this amazing
step through debugger you that
can set watch points ex
execute arbitrary code
expressions.
But in addition we also have
all of these new profile ing
tools.  You saw some of them
just announced thatment     at
the developer keynote, memory,
object allocations and tracking
down issues in your program and
performance problems.  So all of
these tools that we have
announced here at I/O as well as
the one thats you are
particular familiar with use ing
an Android Studio you can apply
those seament tools for
developing for embedded and IoT.
All right.  So that's enough
about talking about what you
probably already know.  Let's
talk about the new stuff.  As
you probably heard yesterday we
announced the new preview of
Android stew      Studio 3.30
and with you               0 and
one of new futures is direct
support for Android things as a
device form factsor.  Let's take
a look at what we have added.
If you are use ing the preview
of Android Studio and you krooe
Tate a              create a new
project, Android things is list
ed as one of those form nak
factors that you can select when
you build a new project. Ing
this         Interesting things
thing to note it is not
mutually ex-Clive      clusive
will phone.  You can build an
application ha    that Dhar gets
targets both phone
and tablet.  Maybe you want to
build a companion application
that goes along with what's run
ning on Android things and you
would like to share as much code
as possible you could actually
build them in to the same
application project just use ing
different entry points via
different activity ies and we
will talk a little bill      bit
more about that.  When I check
that little Android things box
what is being added to my
project?  So what that does is
it walks through and when it kre
ates the new projejt it
automatically adds the on
destroyed things
Android things support
library.  If you have been oug
our document significance
ation you have seen
us telling you to man qually
add these             ly
ually to add these       these
things.
>> LIZ ANDERSON: Destroy
Android things is going to add
them.  The support library adds
a bunch of knewor P
newer PIs with interacting with
low level peripheral devices.
PWM, pie     spooi and all the
spy.  Maybe
you have heard of those things.
But essentially they are all
baer      interfaces that are
used to connect low level ard
hairedware,      ware
hardware.  Now you can
commune kite      icate with
those inside your app and
support library allows you to do
.
>> LIZ ANDERSON: Void
Destroyed
and
Android Studio will tar get that
.  When you create a new project
targeting Android things is an
activity dialogue to add a new
empty activity to your project.
This is also important because
in Android things application
must haved a least          ed
a      at least one main entry
point activity.  So to discuss
that a little bit let me kind of
walk you through what happens
when Android things starts up
for the first time.  So Android
things is a little bit different
than that digsal Android and
that there is a launcher
application on the device.  User
would choose to pick a
particular app and then launch
that so that they can interact
with it.  It is not to say that
Android things doesn't have a
graphical display because it
might.  We have to somehow
provide a mechanism so that ab
Android can automatically
launch whatever the primary
application is that you have
developed once this system fully
boots.  Way way we do that,
once it is finished bool
ed   ed booting there an
intermediary app that is built
in to the system and that launch
er is looking for a very
specific activity of intent on
the system that it can launch as
the first main amount Kaying
application
that's ready to reason whatever
code you have developed.  Now
again if you have done some
Android things development
before you might have seen this
in our documentation but
essentially it means that you
are create ing an activity that
has an intent filter that
includes this IoT launcher
category and the IoT launch
wn  uncher app will look for
a can tift         n activity
and lawn  unch it as the primary
y     pray mere
primary application that on that
device.  You can launch other
applications if you have
multiple APKs but sort of that
single entry point that we
require to get your app up and
running.  And again when you use
the new activity template in
Android Studio what it is going
to do is automatically add all
of that boilerplate to the
manifest for you so that you
don't have to remember to could
that            do that for that
specific activity.  All right.
So one more thing about Android
Studio.  I mentioned before
that there is a possibility for
having a display on an Android
things device    vice but it is
not required.  We say that
displays are optional in Android
things.  Because of of that
there are so    some Android
behaviors that work a little bit
different than traditional
Android.  And one of those is
common is APIs that would show a
dialogue it to a user.  One is
run time permissions, probably
the most comoun.  Now the issue
is showing a run time permission
s dialogue to require access to
particular ape     API we can't
necessary ily do that if there
is no display.  In Android
things these dialogue does not
display and permissions are
granted to applications by
default even if they are
dangerous permissions.  We say
they are granted at install time
will you it             but it
turns out there is a little bit
of an implementation difference
in here that some of you may
have experienced if you is
u you have done the
development so far.  Those per
miles an houring
missions are grant
ed when the device foos
first buys.         boosts.  On
reboot it will grant application
permissions.  There is no
dialogue but during development
this creates a bit of a gap.
There is tul actually a period
of time between when you install
your app on the device the
first time and when it may or
may not have been rebooted where
that permission is not granted
to and that can cause some
friction when you are doing
ing    ing development.  There
are ways around that by manually
rebooting the device or in some
ways      cases you can manual
ly installing the APK use ing
the grant permissions flag to
override all of this.
>> LIZ ANDERSON: Destroyed
Android 3.    Studio 3.0 we do
this for you.  And you download
your code out of Android Studio.
We will automatically grant
those permissions after install
time the way you expect so that
you don't have to do these
manual work arounds or reboot
the device.  All this is now
much smoother and much easier to
work with now that we got full
integration with Android Studio.
show you some of this stuff in
practice.  So I'm going to hand
it over to Renato who is going
to show you a demo.  Can we
switch to the demo, please?  Kis
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  Are
you ready for a life code ing
demo?
(Applause.)
just land      launched Android
Studio 3 dm   .0 which we just
announced yesterday.  You can
download it right now.  It is
public.  But it is on canary
channel yet.  Sos  it is not
stable.  That means it is rigs
risky.  I am going to
start a new project, Android
things project from scratch use
ing the support that we just ed
added and from there we are
going to do something else
.  I would enable form factor
support for Android things and I
will add an anti-activity just
like Dave showed.  And I don't
want to do it UI now because
this -- I will actually run this
app on this device as we    you
can see here.  And this device
has no UI.  No traditional U
ifrment        I.  So thaet's
let's disable that.  Now
it is generate ing a project.  I
will explain a little bit of
what was     device is.  This is
one of the many boards that we
support and on P   top of that
you can see a what we call a hat
which just a board with a bunch
of sensors and buttons and
display segment displays.  We
are going to play with that a
little bit.  Okay.  Here we have
the activity.  If I switch to
my view grader, you can see that
the -- library is added
automatically.  So I'm ready to
do something.  What do you want
me to do day?
DAVE SMITH:
Smith
Dave?
DAVE SMITH:  I guess the
first projeks that everyone
ject that everyone
does is a Blinking light.
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  We
have this notion of driver.  We
don't want      want -- for
every standard peripheral
rif    ipheral, sensor or
display.  So we provide it and
we count on the opportunity
community to provide
he
community to provide more of
those.  High level drivers for
the sensors.  So he don't have
to square        keel      deal
with those low level protoll
toll     tocols you want to
blaing        link a
Blink a light.  With this
particular bord      bee we cite
board we created a
metadrivor that contains every
sensor that has in that board.
So I will start by adding the
dependency on that
.  Driver
.  Is it better?  Okay.
dependency.  This library is
published on J standard.  When I
sync it will add all the
dependency ies.  And why it does
that                  while it
does that I will go back to my
activity.
Now I start with open the LED.
Led     See there are three LE
deshgss        Ds here.  There
is a red, yen     green and blue
and by sues      use ing this
class fronted driver I can't
open if I of         any of
those.  Open the red?  No.
There an exception.  I just --
the full way.
And set the value.  I also
I will set the LED direction
.    as out.  So this is
something that we see in the
send the signal to
and not something that we
collect the signal from.  And I
do that in the loop.  I'm pretty
sure that Dave has something to
tell -- to complain about that.
We will talk about that later
.  Okay.  If you are an Android
developeror you can see that
you can see
what we doing here.  E   We open
up the LED and we got in to a
loop and we set the value every
300 seconds to an alternate
value and now I will run the app
.  Here are the devices I have.
The only device I have connect
ed is the IX7D which is this
board
.  If cross our fingers, please,
if all goes well after some
time the red LED will start
Blinking
.
(Applause.)
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:
Awesome.  I'm done.
DAVE SMITH:  So it works.
That's great.  But you are
pretty experienced Android
developer.  I'm not real sure
that putting an infinite wire
loop in uncreate is the best
weabl       way to handle this.
Do you think maybe we can fix
ha?       that?
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  I
knew he would combine
complain about that.  That's a
very good point.  Despite having
a UI and -- you have to follow
the same rules off Android.  You
should not block the main tread
.  Why?  If you don't have a why
you dote          Y you don't
Y you don't
neat            don't need to
refresh your Y.  Keyboard events
sent to your application and
you have sensor events.  So we
is    have a bun of sduf
ch of stuff.  We sudden
should not block the main track.
That's a main root for and
Croyed          Android and
that's something we are doing
here.  So let's fix that.  The
way I am going to fix this there
are mull      multiple ways to
do it.  You can create a
service.  You can create a
thread.  I would do simplest
way, I create a hammer and
attach that hammer to the main
thread and add each set value to
the end of the looper of the
main thread        tread looper.
It is going to look less
economy         complicated than
it sounds.
mentioned we are ensure ing that
the main thread in Android
continues to remain free so that
system events can still come in
to your application, clr
whether life cycle events or
input events.  It hens
It means in general if you have
to do any regular polling of an
input or something along those
things you want to make sure you
don't do that on the main
thread either.  We are schedule
ing an output to the way we are
doing this is fine.  If we
nutted        need to pull a
sensor or read some value from
irn put     input we might want
to use a background thread.
That      It could be a handling
or thread
handler thread async task or
other things that suit your
development work flow.  They
have all work the same way of
you compm.  But it is im
expect.  But it is
important to realize when you
are working with some of this
hardware it is still good to off
load those regular repeated long
running operations off the main
thread hone      even toe it is
not               though it is
not a network access that you
might traditionally consider as
one of those blocking
applications.  Disokay.
okay
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  Okay.
Good job.
DAVE SMITH:  Sorry.
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  And
now we have the code that
supposedly should work.  Again
let's cross our fingers again.
Actually first let me just go
over it very quickly.  I have
the handler.  The twifrns
difference between now
and before is that now I have a
handle r and the handler is --
all the work that we    the
looper was done ing,    e
ing          doing, run and re
schedule.  It does exactly the
same.  However at the end it
posts itself at the end of the
looper.  So it can do whatever
has to do like reading sensor or
reading keys processing any
event that is coming to a new
thread and then it does another
step and reschedules again.  It
is not specific for anti-things.
This                d
Android things.  You won't know
if it is working or not.  So --
because of it was Blinking
before.  I would change the LED
to the green one.  So we don't
have to trust highway         me
.  Done.
(Applause.)
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:
Awesome.
DAVE SMITH:  That's good.
It is good.  I think we are kind
of with -- we are following a
good pattern.  Disbyte
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  Byte
byte           Bye-bye Smith
submit we                .
DAVE SMITH:  We work for
Google.  Can you get something
more interesting going?
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  We
can do that.  As I mechanicsed
there         ed
mention thissed is one Blink
sensor in this board this tiny
thing here.  Can you see right
here?  It is the BMP280.  It is
temperature and ambient pressure
sensor.  And we can easy ily
connect
to that.  Use ing the rainbow
hat driver.  So let's do it
.  And what I'm going to do did
not         is not only read
from sensor, I will also show
the results like the temperature
on this segment display here.
Right?
DAVE SMITH:  I think that's
a better demo.
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  See.
And how many          how I'm
going to do that, that's really
easy.  Did     Smith whatth
th
DAVE SMITH:  What you may
have noticed,en   the reason for
that is that the driver that we
have written for this specific
peripheral rainbow hat ab tracts
es         stracts that away.
Use ing these drivers is a much
faster way of getting started
without necessary ily having to
deal with with all those low
level details but these drivers
are open source on github and we
will mention a ling to that a
little bit later.  You can use
them as a reference to see how
to build something with these
abstract      stractions use ing
thoem         e ing     ing
them directly and you can read
the code.  Are you done yet?
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  Yes.
On create I initiate the driver
and a few default values and
here in the loop I will keep the
LED.  So you that it is process
ing.  And I will display on the
display the sensor
value.  And that's it
.
DAVE SMITH:  Done.
(Applause.)
is in sellous.
celsius we have to do some
conversion.
DAVE SMITH:  Back to the
slides real quick.  There we go.
Awesome.  So you just seen how
easy it is to get started very
quickly use ing the new Android
Studio to create a new project,
add some code it and communicate
with peripherals and you have
seen how tz    easy it is to in
the Java.  If you heard
yesterday that Kotlin is a first
class citizen in Android Studio
as part of the new prevent
view.  Can we use Kotlin to
develop for Android nings
things?  I don't see why not.
But a simple example of Java I
have flown       thrown up here
to give an idea of what koom
have some of this code might
look like if you are interacting
on interperipherals on the hat.
Communicate ing with the
rainbow LED on the top and it is
doing some base ic setup to
change the color.  This code
snippet is fairly strealt
forward.  It is
straight forward.  What if we
were to same that sample and
write it in Kotlin.  We have
dropped out a little more than
than ten lines of code and you
can see some of the things that
are gone with try catch blocks
are no longer there anymore and
the call back is much cleaner
use ing a lamb ba and even the
initializers are much more
expressive and easy to read and
this code is a lot more concise
and a lot more of a join to even
write.  So what do you think
Renato, can we show them cot
line run     linen
lin         Kotlin running on
the Android things board Smith
dis     board.
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  This
was launched.  What we are going
to could       do here we are
going to start a new project.
You can comp support on one
Android Studio.  You can add
kwot Lynn           Kotlin and
Java at the same time and the
same project.  And you know that
auto aim'           I'm not
cheating here.  I will start a
new project
.
DAVE SMITH:  I will add
Kotlin      cot
Smith
.  I will add Kotlin support
obviously.  Again that's let's
not do a form of tablet.  Let's
do Ann destroyed things
Android things.
Same activity.  Same layout
.  Same U   no UI layout.
DAVE SMITH:  So one of the
things that you can see if you
haven't seen this demo yet when
you include Kotlin support by
default that it maniac tift is
create      kre
in activity is created in
Kotlin but we are automatically
in Kotlin already.
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  Yes,
.  This is the main activity
and it is in Kotlin and it does
nothing.  So now it is my job to
do something with that.  First
I will add the dependency on if
you I goes remember
u you guys remember
well.  The same compend
dpi sendsy   sy
dependency our driver is written
in    gentleman have.  It is
Java.  It
is open source and it is pub lir
ed   ed       lished as a Java A
R.  And the fact that in Kotlin
you can add the dependency and
use it for free, there is no
extra steps.  That's really a
maze ing
.  You know what,
I jers      just remembered
somethingism auto' not
ism     I'm not a Kotlin
developer.
DAVE SMITH:  Is there
something in the IDE that we can
use to help you around?
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  Yes,
.   ,.    .  Lucky ily I kept
it class here.  I add a little
bit more of correctness to it.
And I will copy my class control
C, alt tab, select everything
on the Kotlin side.  This is
copy file, okay?  And I will
control V.  And boom.  Here it
is.
DAVE SMITH:  Automatically
converted in to Kotlin.  You are
a Kotlin developer you just
didn't know.
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  I
just came a Kotlin developer.
This is great.  You don't trust
me, right?  Of course, you don't
.  I wouldn't trust myself.
Let's confer that it is working.
Currently I have the blue LED
here.  So let me change that to
the what color do you want?
Red?  Okay.  Let's do red.  It
shows better on the TV.  See I'm
learning the Kotlin      cot
ing           running
the Kotlin app.  I'm not running
the Java app
.  Launching
.  Boom.  They we go.
(Applause.)
DAVE SMITH:  Anies
Nicely done sir.  Let's switch
back to the slides please
.  Okay.  So we have given you a
very quick tour today of the
new features in Android Studio
that are specific to Android
things as well as just a very
simple walk through of how you
can get started and how quick
and easy it is to get up and run
ning from 0 to a working project
use ing all the tools that are
available here.  A couple of
things while you are here at the
conference that I think you sh
you had check out first all we
are going to be in office hours
immediately after this.  So if
we don't have an opportunity to
answer your questions during Q
and A, you can follow us over
there and we can continue the
discussion.  We have a bunch of
and Croyed          Android
things in the weed      code lab
special         session.
section.  So check
dhoes       those out.  Once you
get home and you want to start
doing some of this development
for yourself check out the
Android things documentation
which is on the  he Android dev
website.  Down Joed the
joun     .  Download the
new and dread         Android
Studio Canary and joint IoT
developers community, us and
other effects         folks from
the other team, are on this
answering questions and pep
helping folks out and watching
you shaur       share your cool
projects.  Check that out as
well.  It looks like we have
some time for questions.  If you
do have queues        questions
feel free to come up to the
mics.  Otherwise thank you very
much for your time today.
(Applause.)
questions?  Okay.  We got one
come ing down
.
>> Hey. Unless I missed
something, when you took the
temperature from the sensor you
didn't -- there was no middle
step between putting it in to
the display.  So I didn't see a
cast to a string, figure ing out
where the floating point went.
(Talking at the same time).
>> How did that go from the
sensor which is probably a
decimal to the -- to that --
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:
Display is also a dryer we
provided  ed
driver we provided and it has
several joe     overrides of the
method.  It has one tore a
string which
for a string.  It gets furs
first four characters of
the string but it also has one
-- one for double, for INT and
for some other data stipes
types.
>> That's dak exactly
what I wanted.  Thank you.
DAVE SMITH:  One other here
.  Stay over here.
>> Quick question. If I want
to customize the OSP version of
Android things to my customer
hardware how much work do I have
to put in the row to connect
things up to the Java API.
DAVE SMITH:  Could you ask
the question again?
>> How much -- low end
interfaces and drivers for the I
TC or other per rif kals that I
have in order to connect to my
upper layer APIs if I have a
custom hardware?
DAVE SMITH:  You are talk
ing about a custom peripheral?
>> Personal box that has one
CPU and a bunch of peripherals
that are attached to it.
DAVE SMITH:  Probably the
most common way that we see
folks doing that is either
implimenting a UR interface or S
PI interface and the anythings
nice things about
those they are blank sheet pro
could tolls that you
could           to
protocol      to
sheet protoll     toll     tocol
s that you can use.
>> Krooifror Driver
hardware will cover Android
things or do I have to develop
everything myself or only part
of the AOSB version.
DAVE SMITH:  All the
functionality to actually
connect to the physical pins on
the device, for instance, the UR
those ooin      APIs are bubble
d all the wail      way up to
Java.  You is    have to define
how the want the data to
transeak between two
transblgt    act twoen
the two         between
between               between
the two.
>> Standard Android apes, ape
APIs, APIs would have
more stuff especially if you
don't have a dpis play.  Seems
diss gs
display.  There may be
standard everies that may not
apply -- your tishgs, developer
IT
developer and use ing that's
standard ape     APIs how do I
know what methods are live
versus what are only for other
deviceses   that are bigger?
DAVE SMITH:  So I would say
bedy fault         dy   dy   dy
default assume it all works.
There is nothing that we have
Is abled  ed            disabled
ed   d out Android API area.
With the exception of any APIs
that require some sort of UI
dialogue to display.  So things
like run time permissions,
another API that's nonfunctional
is owl the         all the
notification I ams       I ams.
APIs.  There is no
system API to display.  So out
side of those display sent treak
centric APIs
everything that you are used to
developing for oncore should
function on Android as well.
>> So the APK runs as a
launcher.  How do you manage if
you want to have multiple apps?
Your own lawn  uncher has to
code other apps.
>> ?
>> Yes the way the system is
designed there is a main sbri
point            bri     entry
pount       point because of
that one activity.  The system
will pick one for you.  You want
to make sure that you choose
one entry point in to there and
then from your code you can
expand that out.  Now as far as
getting them installed right now
it is a bit of a manual process
.  So you could build those
multiple APKs and then essential
ly A to B install all of they
them or if you have
multiple modules in to the AP
studio.  When we could       do
some introductions with the
developer consoles laid inner
later in the year.  You
have to manually install them
if you were doing them on a
regular Android device.  From a
launching perspective we give
you that one instent
intent and then you fan it out
in your code from there.  Any --
other questions?  All right.
Thanks everyone.
RENATO MANGINI DIAS:  Thank
you.
(Applause.)
Judge.
>>
>>.
RAW FILE
GOOGLE I/O 2017
SAN JOSE, CALIFORNIA
MAY 18, 2017
3:30 P.M. CST
STAGE 3
DEFINING MULTIMODAL
INTERACTIONS:  ONE SIZE DOES NOT
FIT ALL
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
1-877-825-5234
+001-719-481-9835
Www.captionfirst.com
***
This text is being provided in a
rough draft format.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART) is provided
in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
***
>>
Straw       Ol    Mull
timodal
.
>>
Where is the other clicker?
Oh, .  Thank you.  No problem.
No problem.  Okay.
ADRIANA OLMOS ANTILLON:
Hell le everyone.
o everyone.  Thank you so much
for join our session.  It is
excite ing to be here and
welcome to our session on
multimodal interactions.  So we
would like to start introducing
my colleague Jared Strawderman.
He is part of the
conversational design team and
he is designer for the Google a
ssistant.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  And
this is my e stemmed colleague
Adriana Olmos Antillon.  She a
productor designer where she is
in charge of the design effort
for third party multimodal
experiences.  Before we dive
right in I wanted to share a
spernl        personal store y,
a story that I feel capture as
real world example of the moil
multimodal.  I was trifr
traveling to Asheville
north Carol lie in October to
kearl
li              North Carolina
to attend a wedding of two of my
friends.  I am originally from
West Virginia and north Carol
lie in            kearl
li              North Carolina
is not that far away.  I didn't
have a good idea where to get
dinner.  My hotel had a concierg
e desk and I talked to the conci
erge about what you liked and
didn't like.  We went back and
forth and he was asking me
questions about how far I was
willing to go and whether I had
a car and after he talked to me
for     me for awhile, he
did something bre interest
very interesting.
He narrowed it down to a few
strunt        straunts and then
straunts and
then
restaurants and then handed over
the menus to those restaurants
and I made a decision and I told
the cocierge that we had decide
d to go to this southern
restaurant at which time he
actually resumed the dialogue
between me and him and he said
when you want to go how many
people are going and he made the
is he rememberization
reservation for
me.  The Voice part is represent
ed by the dialogue between me
and the concierge and the I have
sthal            visual part
represented by the menus.
Designing multimodal experiences
is an interdisciplinary effort.
My background is in Voice
design.  So I have been design
ing conversational interfaceor
s for several years.  Anything
that involves spoken input and
the things that you hear, that's
my area of expertise.  Adre
dre    dre    dre    driana
comes from a more traditional
web design act ground
background.  But it takes
combine ing these bo    two erts
efforts along with things
like motion design, UX write ing
and visual design to create a
really cohesive monothyic
experience.  Before        Let's
take a quick step back and talk
about how we as humanings
ing     beings experience things
in the real world.
ADRIANA OLMOS ANTILLON:
Imagine the last time you were
walking on the beach.  You could
hear the oceans and touch it.
And it is only senses trigger
that -- it makes it compelling
experience.  Flight controls is
not -- mostly three main senses.
Site, hearing    g
Sight hearing and touch.
We consume controls is based on
sight and hearing.  So we are
going to be focusing in these
two.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  In
order to have any chance at all
of designing a compelling
multimodal experience an
absolute prerequisite for you to
know what modallity does well
and what it does poorly.  For
example, Voice does some things
really really extremely well and
other things it is abjectly
ly   ly table         ly   ly
terrible at.  And it is really
important for you to recognize
what those are.  You can re
letter vaj
letter           leverage the
strengths and avoid the
availability
liability ies.  So let's start
with Voice.  So Voice is very,
very good at having a menu
structure and provide ing
directs access
t               e ing     ing
direct access to what you need.
I used to think that the mobile
bsh     -- my mobile device was
the epitomy of convenience and
I have really quick access to
information and every facet of
my life is on this gut
beautiful device but then when I
started   ed   ed interacting
with going get         Google
Home across the room I was able
to ask it across the room what's
the score of Virginia
basketball and it would give it
to me.  Compare ing it to pull
ing my phone out of my pocket
and unlock eking     ing
lock     locking it and --
there is the score.  When you do
that with a far field
interaction it makes pulling the
phone out of your pocket seem
intoo       too inconvenient
vein.        vein
vooent.  As compel
convenients  as compel
ling and excite ing as the
benefits Voice are it doesn't
woman without         come
without
comwithout            come
without Is    its draw whacks.
back.  Usersen   can
only attain a finite amount of
content in their memories.  Is
You have to manage that.  So
for those of you who may have a
visual design background or for
those of you who have developed
websites and mobile application
s imagine if the only visual
affordance that you had to
present content to your users
was a scrolling ticker that goes
across the screen and the user
can only remember that text that
just e var possible
vaP pore right       e
rated on the edge of the sken
screen to help them get
through the interaction and this
is what we as designers have to
manage.  And I'm not even sure
if it had a chance to cycle all
the way through but that's what
the ticker said.  So lufrs
ously content           ly
big chunks of content are
better presented and lot easier
for user  r  rs to absorb on a
static screen.  Say I want to
ask for the hours for a
restaurant in and     San hey
sew.            Jose.  Here is
one approach to answering that
question.
>> Black sheep is open today
from 5 o'clock to 930  :30 p.m.
and tomorrow from 5 o'clock to
10 p.m.  On Saturday from 0   5
o'clock to 10 p.m.  On Sunday
from 10 ament       a.m. do 2
p.m. and again from 5 o'clock to
9 p.m.  And they are closed on
Monday.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  While
it is a good idea -- when you
present so much content that the
user can't block any of it
becomes
meaningless.  Here is another
approach to that.
>> Black sheep is open today
from 5 o'clock to 930  :30 p.m.
Here are the hours for the rest
of the weekT so   .
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  Do you
give the more salient
informations              pieces
of informations up sfront
front and you refer to
the deans       screen for more
dense content that the user can
use ats their leisure and what
are the drawbacks of use ing
Voices and interfaces is when I
talk to Google assistant, people
can hear me.  That's kind of
how talking worings
ing    ing works.  Imagine if
the person next to you right
here in the middle of Adrian na
a about to say something
provide         profound and
anoise     maze ing and decides
to pull out a phone and asks
Google assistant what the name
of the bass ket   s
score the bass kel     ket
ball game was on Tuesday.  And
even though the devices is cap
able of it is really mimics the
range and access of Voice
interactions in public settings
like this.  By the way if you
really interested in this topic
there is an incredible session
hamming         happening at 330
:30 today on stage 5 and he is
going to be talking about the
right use cases, right Voice
interactions for your
application.  I highly recommend
it
.
ADRIANA OLMOS ANTILLON:
Visual interfaces can be as
permanent or complex and dynamic
as wes     we want it to be.
In fact, it is a -- there is a
lot of information that can be
delivered.  Take, for instance,
a sample as classic light and we
can control the time ing of the
red to green in order to convey
some meaning or be as
sophisticated as (inaudible)
where you can consume, follow up
what is happening, what is
trending and what is bad or not
bad video.  There are a lot
things that you can do in one
screen.  Now the question is how
are you go        you going to
be provide ing   e ing     ing
visual information in a way that
is beyond passive consumption
and that's actually for the
interactive experiences and one
of those is true conversation
and in a natural conversation
that we have with people we
point things, we describe things
.  And this is back and forth
among human beses   ings.  So
just happen natural.  And the
thing is like we start thinking
about applications and how map
ping     ing             happen
ing on mobile, they throw a lot
of information and convey that
but we have to be careful.  For
instance, l   the mobile app
for, there are some things that
I can quickly do but if you
remember the last time you are
walking to the store, we actual
ly have a conversation with the
person and then information,
information that is delivered
back and forth.  So if you put
those two together they real
look really different.
And in fact,
probably small person would
chat from experience with the
assistant.  So one important
piece of information you take in
to account is the person have a
oP   n app on the foint
he phone, should be the start
ing point and remember you
should be -- in order to start
building your applications
.  So one of the directions is
not something -- and it is --
and how space in the past
.  Found in the background and
then you have the -- and then
you follow along.  So one of the
things happening and multimodal
experience as well.  We also
experience asking you for
questions and then -- but when
we have to -- we have to think
how are you going to be combine
ing these two modality ies in a
way that is not bad to the user
.  Sense of highways
these mow dality ies.  Various
visual and this is going to the
tab -- because we -- we know how
to design for all.  And that is
the decision this.  It is not
that simple and there is a lot
of factors that we knee to take
need to take in to
consideration.
So we are going to be talking
about these factors that we want
ed to take and position, when we
think of all these platforms
that we are going to be design
ing for.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  We want
ed to talk a little bit about
the factors that we have
identify ied to help you think
about how your experiences will
manifest as going gel a
going             Google assist
ant comes to more surfaces and
the fact is device designed to
used at the used walking, run
ning or driving and some other
situation that makes the screen
otherwise enact es sibl
in ak ccess
accessible.  Think of your
phone as apposed to     ed
pose        opposed to
the TV.  Is the device designed
to be use in private or anywhere
or a one-to-one relationship
between the user and the device
like your phone or is it design
ed to shared among a group of
users like the Google Home.  The
next is prox yilt,      imity.
So are you close enough to
quickly tap on the device to
interact with it.  As opposed to
something like the Google Home
or your TV it is optimized for
far field interactions.  The
next is audio capability, does
your device just have a very
small Mick that be
mic that can capture speech from
a few feet away or does it have
an entire array and designed to
capture speech from across the
room and, of course, visual
capability, do you have a fall
ergon
omic kwar        ic   ic
question            ic   ic
QWERTY key dward      board or
something more primitive like a
V pad on a TV row mote and
remote and visual out
put and that boils down to
screen size.  So these are
factors that we want you to
consider and keep in mind and we
are going to go through a few
of these and where we anticipate
that it may show up.  So keep
in mind this is kind of a future
looking forward looking
presentation to give you some
guidelines by which to
anticipate how to deploy your
actions on other surfaces.  So
let's talk about Google Home
since it was stuch       such
prominute in any eventually
ly
min         prominently in
yesterday's keynote and it is
going a lot of traction in the
marketplace.  I mentioned before
how Voice is really incredible
at flattening the infrastructure
and there is another upside of
speech is that I think is real
ri   ly important to present in
the context of Google Home and
it is that speech, what I am do
ing right now that is the
interface.  You are ability
able to interact with
Google Home in way that you have
been doing since kwo     two
years old.  There aren't any
manuals.  There is no tutorials
and there is no learning curve.
All you have to do is know what
kinds of features going
Google assistant generally
supports like weather and
supports.  And you just ask for
those things the which       way
you would ask another person.
So if we look at some of the
factors that I outlined earlier,
if we look about whether the
users in motion they are not.
You put --    your Google Home
on a kitchen counter or night
stand and it is usually planted
ed   ed there for quite
awhile.  Google Home is the
deplored in the private setting
but it is shared among a group
of users.  So it is somewhat
private.  And you don't have to
be close enough to interact with
it.  It is hospitalize
optimized for far field
interaction and if we look at
input, output capability ies it
has strong capability ies for
audio book, input andout    out
put but very little on the
visual side.  We three kind of
overarching guidelines for how
to design for assistant in
action on Google Home.  And the
first one is don't read, listen
and what I mean by that is as
you build actions and as you
develop experiences on Google
Home you may be pulling content
from some online source or
something and a lot of resources
are optimized for writ content,
ten content.  They are
designed   ed   ed to be read
and you maybe something to think
you can just sake      take
these sources and run them
through a text-to-speech engine
and you have your Voice
interface.  It is no, the that
simple.  Let's           ilar
It
is not that simple.  Weather
boer cast           forecast
this string of text makes
perfect sense to you.  If I were
to Translate this since
sing      string of text in to
something that is appropriate
for spokesen language.  In
Mountain View it is sunny 77
degrees and winds knot      knot
north nert      north west
10 to 15 miles an hour.
>> (Off microphone).
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  Totally
incomprehensible.  So just --
when you get a data source and
you run it through make sure it
is appropriate for spoken
content.  Just take a few
samples and run them through the
text-to-speech engine and don't
look at the text.  Listen to it
to see if you can understand it
.  The next one is avoid
information overload.  I have
already kind of lamented about
the e femorale nature of speech.
Just be careful how much
content you present to the user.
So I ask Google assist anlt on
home              ant
ssistant on home, this is one
abroach      pproach.
>> One is what's movies are
out in your favorite theater.
Pay field           Faye maled
May field.  Snatched
.  The fast and furious.  Smur
fes, in a circle.  Do anies of
y of those sound good.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  Not
only does it bombard you with 12
movies but it force yous     s
you to make a decision.
>> 12 m movies playing at
your favorite theater.  Dial
Doo ri of a         diary
of a women P kid, should
women P         wim
py kid, sh should I tell you
about them or keep going?
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  Answer
the question.  So here is what I
mean.  If you have something
like a map or the user is asking
for directions or navigation, a
map really is efficient as
communicate ing information in
this really nice come pablgt
pact reck tan
tangular shape.  It conveys how
far you are from your
destination and what the prefer
red route is and what traffic
looks like all that kind of
stuff.  So it may be tempting to
just punt to the screen on
interactions like this.  So
when Google Home was first
dy    ke    deemployed and
people    ep            ed
ploi      deployed and
people were asking questions
about navigation.
>> I don't have a screen. So
I can't do that for you.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  So
pretty disapointing and un
helpful.  So we learned our
lesson.  We thought about why
people are asking Google Home
these questions and we kind.
Distilled a few salient points
about what beepel are asking
el         pem
people are asking for.  In the
Bay Area the kwint sent tell
question, what's traffic look
like.  How longs is it
How long is it going
to take me to get.  We took
this approach insend it
stead.
>> The best way to get to
work by car is trueing
through 87 and is 0      101
north and it will take 19
minutes in light traffic.
>>.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  The
image of a map is much more
efficient and convey a lot more
information to the user, there
is nofr      no reason why you
can't distill the most sail jent
lient piece of
information in to a verbal
summary.  Let's talk about
Smartphones.
>>
ADRIANA OLMOS ANTILLON:
Mart      Smartphone is a within
wonderful Finance
machine that we take
everywhere in our lifrs
.  Volume would be up one minute
and next timing it goings
going to be dub and run
done and running
through a session and headphones
.  This is, for instance, this
example, as you see in Canada
and I was up there,  in the ski
slopes and we needed that -- we
knew there was going to be a
snowstorm and we needed to know
what time to get down from the
highly        hills P and it was
and it was at a
time that we could ask the phone
and hey when the snow gorm
starm      storm going to start
and because the last thing we
wanted to do is take out our mit
off our mit tens
mit tens              miten
s.  This is a time where we
could use our phone as a little
phone to carry in our pocket.
There were times that we were
running and navigate ing in
traffic and you wish you could
speak to your phone and answer
your question.  In that example
the last thing we want to do is
have this information be blit
blit you want
built.  So you they need
to (cutting snuchlt
ing    ting out).  We can be
starting in one position and
then other things        times
we are running to places and we
can send a very private or
public context and what is
wonderful about we can rich
interactions with them.  What is
more compelling is that there
is a lot of capability ies at
the       .  At the keynote we
saw this excite ing demo
westbound           woor
where e can use camera
we can use the camera
as a form of input.  We came up
with three guidelines that we
have been oef   (Off
microphone)
oef     observe
ing.  In one mode goes away they
are the              the other
one should take over.  Say I was
sending a third party
application and what kipling it
tells me facts about numbers.  I
pull up the phone and it greets
me and is there in person and
enter the conversation.  And it
gives me suggestions of what I
could say or I can say
(inaudible).
It is kind of like -- never pay
ing attention to the screen.
>> Howdy this is
Kipling.  I can tell you facts
and trivia.  What number you
would like to know about.
ADRIANA OLMOS ANTILLON:
This is the random response and
if you   u you pay attention,
introduce things like this is
the --
because we didn't have an
artificial key and we add little
situations as part of dialogue
to come to the kals      values
that I could say and give them
ideas and --
because you already have a
suggestion to chat bubble.  It
is very interesting that we
optimize the mode that allows
for both.  Let's see another
example.  It is time and those
things that wanted to do at
beginning of this month.  And
then we can ask -- to deliver
the assistance for the
next -- and it is simple and
normal to see -- free up in
every website and this is -- we
can quickly scan things.  Then
the question is like how is it
going to be presenting this to
auditory content
.
>> Okay. Theware yors have
ware      warrior
s have a (inaudible).  Which one
do we want tickets for?
say things like okay.  We are
having this conversation and --
a little bit about what is
going to show up in a little bit
and I won't start by a surface
that was mentioned in yesterday
's keynote to TV.  So if we
quickly look at some of the
conditions around how to do the
-- TV is deployed.  It is a
staticky advice.           did
device.  It is not move
ing and even though there is --
it is not going to move with it
.  It was design and used in a
private setting among the group
of users much like Google Home
and it is too far away to touch
to interact with it.  Now this
is the interesting thing about
the TV.  Look at the where this
is on the output scale compared
to the input scale.  Very, very
rich audio and visual output
capability but quite mod l
erate or limited to input
capability ies.  What does that
tell us?  That tell us that the
TV is is a consumption device
and not really anything sense
interaction device and I think
the reason that we are kind of
bringing this up as you
anticipate your actions come ing
to life, through the real
assistant on TV, know that we
have to kind of minimize it on
to a banner
on about a the bol      he
bottom third of the kren
screen so not disrupt active
prom      programming going on
as the TV is being played.
Because it is primary ily a
consumption device and people
watch programs and weigh want
we want to leverage
that bottom field ael estate
real estate.  And
because we have a few car people
in the audience I wanted to
touch a little bit on cars in
Google assistant on cars and
Andrew is -- it does a yut
but job of audio rich
content by way of projex of
phone                 jex of
phone on to your car's
interface.  It was move ing
around, it is carrying you
around at 80  #0   0 miles an
hour.  Drivers shouldn't me be
looking at the screen a lot.
And even though cars are out and
about -- the kind of a private
setting.  And users generally
have access to quick touch
interaction in a car
from a car to adjust their
temperature or change the
station or something like that
but you don't want the driver
interest,  beshg agt
interacting with
things a lot.  Should be drive
ing erment          e ing
ing.  In terms of ifrn put
inn     input output
put    put capability.  There is
nothing wrong with a lot of
spoken output and they have
pretty decent mic and sometimes
recognition is a challenge of
that am pee yent         bient
noise.  If we overlay Google
Home on top of the car they are
strike ingly similar in terms of
where they fall on this matrix.
What does that tell us?  That
tells us that Google Home is a
very, very Voice only device.
And that tells us that the car
probably should be somewhere in
that range as well.  So a few
take-aways as we kind of
summarize here.  If you don't
take anything away from today's
talk, please take this away.
Know the strengths and weakness
es of Voice as opposed to
visuals.  Leverage what's
age    age what speech
does well, leverage what the
screen does really well and voi
void      avoid the
liability ies that we talked
about.  Optimize for the
strongest mode but allow both.
If the skreb       screen does
something better point the views
or         user to the screen
but still let them do it in
Voice and even though these
interactions involve both visual
and auditory modes they usually
invoked by a spoken input.  So
make sure that the first bit of
content that you are hearing is
appropriate for spoken language.
And one of the overarching
principles of use ing Google
agel   ssist ants when it
ant is we want them to be
efficient.  And each turn in a
conversational dialogue should
be really short and sweet and
easy for the user to absorb and
consume and help them get
through their interaction.
ADRIANA OLMOS ANTILLON:  So
we talked a lot today about how
to package a response and make
ing sure that all these
modality ies cohesively make a
compelling a response and there
to say this one is absent.  And
we also talk about
conversational design and how
many important is to be inspired
from having a conversation with
a human before we jump in to
which is a sign of     n
sign in application but the work
did     -- there is a lot of
Google we need to get moving.
Someones          Once we have
our response, how is that -- we
are going to be representing
this response automatically,
that it is take ing in to
account the cop     context in
which the use, whether they are
running, how we present that
snfgs       information or if
they are passive, sitting on the
couch.  So how -- more and more
can do these changes between
one type of service in to
another in a matter that is
almost magical and the use offer
doesn't              r doesn't
vunt      have to skr for it
ask for it.  Multimodal
interactions on the phone how
we can make these interactions
like these in cars and thaul
these things that people can
interact with more dynamic to
allow for more complacent
tractions in a way that is more
rich and introduced.  So we are
very excited that you guys are
joining the journey and start
building your applications with
us.  There is going to be a lot
of other talks happening today
and tomorrow.  You are welcome
to join in case you are interest
ed in the talk for the Google
assist antd     ant and there is
is a challenge and we can work
to see all the things that you
will be submitting     ing
ting to it.  Thank you very
much.
(Applause.)
Since we have five minutes of
time, if one person has a
question, feel free to ask
.
>> Hi. I saw from the
presentation that you did a
context and show for the maps
experience where -- because the
person lives in Bay Area, just
give ing that direction, based
on what the Bay Area people use.
But for other countries, do
you currently allow multi
contextual responses?
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  I'm
sorry could you are y Pete the
question?
>>
e y   refeet    peat the
question?
>> For the Bay Area people
understand what these two
highways mean but for -- Korea
or somewhere, this is my -- it
would be meaningful to them.
Does the current technology
allow us to give context depend
ing on what the user  r  r?
>> For third party
experiences I don't believe so.
>> Contextual.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  Can you
elaborate?
>> You said if the user is --
The map am    example should
apply ever where.  We are trying
to kun Kated do
communicate to the user what the
referred route is.  The trooifl
travel time that allies
to      y   pply ies anywhere
where you live.  The bus route.
It is not -- I was only --
because one of the key decisions
that travellers like commuters
in the Bay Area have to make is
280 or 101.  I'm give ing that
as an example.  Sorry for the
confusion.
>> Thank you.
>> Great presentation. One
of the things that I was really
disapointed to see when I was
bigs      digging in on aist
ssistant actions some actions
are not supported on certain
kinds of devices.  I was wonder
ing it strikes it mae     makes
it hard to like make user aware
of your app, for example, and
what it can do.  I was wondering
if you had any thoughts about
even if you could be something
better, like you talked about,
still probably need to support
all the same use cases across
those different surfaces.  Any
reaction to is that?
that?
ADRIANA OLMOS ANTILLON:  So
first of all you are right.  We
are starting to make sure there
is -- across --    surfaces and
it is something that is very
important to us.  In terms of
the survey and make ing your
users aware of what      whether
these apps are available there
is a talk on cover
discovery that is going to be
talking about in order to have
to make your apps discovery on
other surfaces.  And the third
waun that           one that we
touch upon, we are ston      con
stantly working to make sure the
way we are code ing your
application is not -- response
that mannest    ifests on
different surfaces.  So the
probable    lem you are having
is also we are having at the
moment because we have to
support all these multiple -- it
is something that we are
trooifr strooi
strooiing for        ing
strive ing for.  You are
not alone.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  By the
way did you see the session is I
think was this morning dedicate
d for discovery of your app?
You missed it.  Okay.  Just
watch it on Youtube
.
>> It was interesting to see
that, you know, the user
considerations for home for
Google Home and for the car were
very similar.  That said there
are things in the car that, you
know, have legal considerations
you don't want to have them look
ing ats        ing    ing at the
screen and things like that.
Does the developer know that the
person is going -- in the car
or how is it that the developer
is going to know where --    the
context is?
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  Yeah,
there was a session in the queue
key foet     note this
northerning             morning
where you get a signal wlrl a
screen is available
not.  We have to look in to see
whether you are getting some
surface information.  But those
-- there is a community in G
plus called actions on Google.
And you can kind of go there and
ask questions but that's one of
the things that Adriana was
talking about.  We want to do a
better job provide ing just in
time signals for you to know the
user's conditions wet ter.
>> better.
>> That won't be enough that
the screen is available or not
because there is a screen in the
car.
>> .
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  Right.
ADRIANA OLMOS ANTILLON:
Yeah, and also to build on your
concern like also it is
important to take in to
consideration where in that
country is going running because
the policies of make ing the
screen available changes from
place to place.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  But as
we firm up kind of how we are
dealing with the car there are
probably going to be restriction
s about what you are going to be
able to present as a developer
on the  he car screen.  So I
don't think you are going to
even be allowed to do some of
the things that you are talking.
Just because of all the reason
s that you mentioned.  It is a
good question and then, of
course, there are some fends
frendz tsz
frends        friends of mine,
what happens when you move in to
the realm that the cars are
drive ing themselves.  That whoa
whole equation goes out
the window.
>> Thank you.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  I think
-- we will try to do two.
>> One quick question. Do
you have experience with longer
conversations, for example, I
wanted someone to fill out a
form.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  Yes, .
>> This is not a Dirk give me
the                  -- give me
a web information.  But two,
three paining         pages --
ADRIANA OLMOS ANTILLON:
Yeah, .
>> Maybe pick it up.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  Yeah, .
Yeah, .  Actions require an lot
of turn take ing and just -- we
just released on this session
with I/O documentation provided
examples and how you can have a
kvrngs        conversation with
transactions for when      what
you have to do if you have to
buy flowers or    what's
or what's all steps if you have
to buy shoes.  First approach is
to multi but definitely you can
find information there in
examples to get inspired.
>> So you don't think it is
out of the realm of having
longer discussions and ongoing
sdugs
going      going discussions
about the certain topic?
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  Go a
head.  I think that as long as
we have kind of pause and resume
type model I don't think that's
out of the question.  But if
you are trying to do it on fell
swoop it is             sweep
swoop it is not advise
able.  Yeah, .
>> Thanks.
>> Thank you.
>> I just had a question
about these abilities on
different platforms and types of
interactions you are talking
about Voice and you are talking
about images.  And visuals.  I
know gesture control isn't
either of your areas of
specialty.  But do you have any
kind of insights on what you
guys' thoughts are on gesture
control and where you plan to go
with that in the future and how
important that is for the flat
orm          plart
platform?
ADRIANA OLMOS ANTILLON:
Gesture control is not something
we have been focusing about.  I
would be going out of the area
but definitely something worth
explore ing a lot more.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  And
haptics is one thing that we
very, very every so delicately
touched on in this presentation.
That's another factor, too.
>> Okay. Thank you.
JARED STRAWDERMAN:  Thanks.
Okay.  Thanks.  AvP
(Applause.)
>>.
>>
RAW FILE
GOOGLE I/O 2017
SAN JOSE, CALIFORNIA
DATE
TIME AND TIME ZONE
STAGE NUMBER OR ROOM NAME
SESSION NAME
SESSION NUMBER
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
1-877-825-5234
+001-719-481-9835
Www.captionfirst.com
***
This text is being provided in a
rough draft format.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART) is provided
in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
***
>>
>> Thanks.
>> Is it silenced?
and I work on security research
and today with you we work on
web security research and Eric
who works on webmaster
relationship.  We are going to
tern      tell you about how we
can learn about web security
with Google.  Let's do a quick
show of hands.  How many of had
website compromised or know
someone who has a website hack
ed?  Come on.  Don't be
Shea      shy.  Raise your hand
.  This is not -- almost
most of you raise your hands.
It is not surprise willing
ing.  In 2016 hacking
has never been so prevalent.  We
found 32% more websites
compromised than ever.  Try to
hack your sweb site for many
years from attacking your user
by sending malware to them or
try to phic sh to use ing   e
ing     ing resources to try to
steal your data and expose them.
Either when you get hacked,
the consequences are pretty dear
.  You are also      lose ing
the trust of your user and
potentially financial loss.
Solve       Some of the lasting
efrt         ing    ing effort
ing    ing effects user
trust can take years to cover
ever recover
recover.  This is why it is
essential to keep security at
the forefront of your web
strategy and make sure you in
vest in security from when you
develop new things, what you
maintain it and when you create
it.  I'm prit      pretty sure
you already know that ouz
otherwise you would not be here
today.  Today what we are
interesting             going to
do we are going to wouk
walk you through the resource
that going bell provides
Google provides and
help defend against hackers.
First Eric will cover how you
can get help from Google when
you get hacked.  What are the
resources we have to help you
clean up and to help you secure
your website and then with you
on we are going to give you a
sneak preview of our upcome ing
web security source
courses and to make it very
practical and give you a sense
of what you are going to learn
we are going to tifr      give
you a short yoer      overview
followed by a sneak preview of
one of the lectures and because
we wanted to have something
which is very hands on we have a
lot of demos today that is --
if it would beingers
works and jump right in.
ERIC KUAN:  First off hi
mom.  I'm on live stream right
now and my mom is watching so
ing    ing.  So I'm super
excited about that.
(Applause.)
ERIC KUAN:  Hi mom.  Let's
jump in to what you should do if
your site gets hacked.  You are
going to get some type of
notification from Google's
perspective that notification is
e-mail that you have may have
seen or some type of
notification in search results.
They don't have to come from
geg     Google.  In your suesor
user are e-mailing you
and saying there is something
wrong with your site.  You want
to check dhoes out
chose       those out.  If your
site is compromised it is really
annoying and worth of all your
users are trying to get to your
site and they can't get to your
site.  So it is in your best
interest to keen      clean up
as soon as possible.  Now the
process of cleaning up it can be
quite daunting.  It is going to
take some time.  But if you
follow these steps methodically
is there is a high chance that
you can clean your site.  The
first thing is to quarantine
kwarn     quarantine
your site.  Taking it offline or
site      isolate it to certain
parts take certain parts off
line.  If    You want to change
any user maim       r  r names
passwords the whole being you
don't want to be hacked while
you are trying to fiks      fix
your site and don't       you
don't want your users trying to
get to your site while it is
compromised.  Take ing your site
offline temporary ily is the
best move want           you aen
move and you want to
start building your team.
Identification, this is probably
the most difficult part and the
most time consume ing.  Hackers
are constantly trying to
prevent you from remove ing the
hack on your site.  So they will
do weird little tricky things
like clicking ab you     and you
are go where this page is show
ing an http404 and it is serve
ing Spam to your users and
search engines.  Identification
is important.  But at this phase
you will also want to identify
the vulnerability because you
want to understand how hackers
got in to your site.  Cleaning
up is just about remove ing
those files and then testing
make ing sure that your site is
running low again.  That's the
main part of cleaning up and
that's really all you need to do
.  Match       Patching is about
close ing those vul
negotiatibility ies   y       e
nerability
nerability ies that you
identified earlier.  A lot of
people miss this and their sites
do get compromised again.
Don't fore get to close those
vulnerability ies.  You can just
update your site software, CMSs
or   your plug-ins things like
that.  And they will close a lot
of vulnerability ies.  Finally
if your site was flagged by
Google and you saw those red
initials on your site or some
warnings in search results you
want to tell gook that your
Google that your site
was cleaned   ed   ed and they
can remove those flaegs
flags.  The steps works for most
types of hacks and we realized
that a lot of hacking campaigns
they work in very, very similar
ways and this helps us under
stand how attackers are scale
ing their attacks.  How they
are trying to fly under the
radar, go against detection and
this also helps build better
detik   tection systems and we
have identify ied three major
hacking campaigns so far the
cloaked key words where they
create cloaked pages and drop
key woords        words on the
pages.  Gibberish attack,
ish    ish hack, use ing
e ing     and when users
click in they get redirected to
Spammy   y  my malware sites.
The finally the Japanese key
woords injection and this tar
gerts Japanese brand name goods
and attempts to sell them fake
goods.  We have been able to
create really great
ly   ly great documentation step
by step guides for each one of
these hacks.  I will link you to
the documents in a second
because I think it will help if
you or your friendsor someone
that you                    or
someone that you know has been
hacked or will be hacked in the
future.  First though I want to
talk you through the Gibber hack
.  Understanding how these hacks
works are super interesting
because they had Lep you with
remediation in the future.  Now
this is what the Gibber hack
looks like.  It is realingly
plain         ly   ly
really plain and trying to use
the domain to link well.  The
underlie  ying mechanics behind
it are also pretty simple when
you put it in to three separate
pieces.  The user clicks on the
site, redirected in some way or
fashion to a Spam page, to a PHP
jaen      ask     generate or
script and then users are retlek
directed to the Spam.  So
the first important part of this
whole chain is this redirect.
If you can identify how that re
direct is happening, where it is
happening, you can identify the
other parts of the your site
that have been comoms
compromised as well.  And this
example the HT access file has
been compromised.  Through
Three lines of code it
is going row direct your users
come ing from major search
engines and then send them to
this page right here, the Spam.h
p p  php page.  This is the
piece that you want to identify
later.  It is not going to be
called   ed   ed Spam.php.  We
have seen hackers call things
called horse duck 2 and try to
mask as core files instead of W
P-config.  They are trying to
trick users from accurately   ly
ly fixing their sites.  Okay.
So from the redirect we see
that you are sent to the page
generate or.  Now you are
probably going to open this file
.  You want to figure out what's
going on.  You are curious.
You are curious you had
how they are doing all this dpaj
and you are going
damage and you are
going to get something like.
They have enscript
script       crypt.  They don't
It is really
difficult to understand what a
lot of these scripts are doing.
Even if you do you take the
time to figure out, you know,
this is exactly what the code
is, it is still not really human
readable.  This is not code ing
e ing     ing best practices.
Your CS professors would be
appalled by looking at this.
You need to remove this file.  I
would ask that you back up
these files just in case just in
case they are good files and
later on if you do want to do
some forensic work it would be
helpful to have these back up
files.  You can see these two
files that      they have done a
lot of damage to a website.
And so that's why you don't even
want to be in the phase of
cleaning up a website.  Cleaning
a website is difficult.  It is
especially financially costly
and it is annoy no, Iing.  You
ing           ing.
You have brand reputation on the
line and that's why the key
take away is that prevention is
key.  So let's talk about a
couple of quick things that you
can do today right after the
session in order to meP     help
with revengs         prevention
.  Back up your site.  There is
a lot of people that don't back
up their site and that's baffle
ing to me.  Pack P        Back
up your site as often as
possible.  If you get compromise
d one of the easy yes, sir ways
to over              ier
easier ways to
recover restore the backed up
version of your site.  The
vulnerable that the hackers got
to probably still exist.  So you
want to fix that.  Sekdzly
signed up for
ly          Sekdzly   ly
Secondly in up for search
cob     console.  This is one
of the ways that Google
communicates with webmasters.
And finally update your code,
your themes like I said before
this is one of the most common
ways that attackers compromise a
site.  And I know this is
difficult because I have talked
to a developer before and she
said my client they don't want
to update their site because if
we update the core CMS files
they are going to mess up a
whole bun P of plug-ins.  But it
is in your client's best
interest to update and you have
to convince them.  You have to
talk to them about make ing a
site that is boths secure
both skwuren
secure and still works for them.
That's the really important
bees      piece.  As I said
earlier there is a lot of
documentation that going gem
Google can give to help
you.  And that's where our
security guides are.  The ones
for the specific hack campaigns
that we have identify ied and we
are con stontly building more
of these guides for different
types of hacking things that we
have identify ied.  The second
thing is the webmaster help
forums.  We have a lot of
awesome top krk     krsh
krb     krshtors
contribute or to help you re
mediate your site and identify
any vulnerables
nerability ies and follow us on
Twitter.  We will give you up
dates about search and security.
I am going to hand it back to
Elie to talk to you about the
second part of secure ing your
site and that's building a safer
website.
ELIE BURSZTEIN:  Thank you.
said when it comes to security
prevention is key and so far at
Google we didn't have much of a
public course to help you out.
So we did     decided in the
last year and a half to develop
a new security force which is
meant to be very hands on so you
can have a very practical
knowledge that you can apply to
security your website.  The core
idea whined        behind the
koes       he course
to have a short focus lecture
on core concept and a lot of
your site sko cow         so you
can have hands-on experience
and knowledge to help protect
your site.  So last week it was
-- I will do what the course
looks lib     like.  The course
will be a set of 12 lek turs
which will be grouped in to
three main categories.  First
thing we are going to discuss
how to handle user data safely
ly   ly from how do I
authenticate my use     user,
how do I maintain safely and how
do I encrypt my communication
so that when they interact with
website your use the site.  The
second thing we are going to
cover is web attacks.  These are
attacks that are specific to
web security and you need to
know to make sure they -- you
are noul      not vul ner ebl
nerable to them.  We are
going to cover the four big ones
which is comshgs         XSS
and CSRF and S   SQL injection
and click jacking.  Embed a
widget from a third party
website and if you get hacked to
how do you deal with user
content and how do I make sure
that I don't have toxic content
on my website and doiPt
don't famous a picture in to my
beautiful stream and as Eric
said when you get haked it is
difficult
ed        hacked it is difficult
to recover and you concrete
case of hacking so you can learn
how to investigate them and
clean up.  So if the event that
you get hacked, you already
prepared.  So for each lek is
your we            cture we are
going to provide you a few
materials.  We are going to give
you slides where we can review
the lecture, we will do a video
of the slide with some
explanation and the most impart
portant part we will give
you exercises and quizzes so you
know how well you are doing and
if you have understood the
concept.  So it was a real
development point we have built
a ton of those.  We have over 50
compersz          exercises for
you.  They are going to be in
beautiful aspect, web security.
First you have attack exercise
where you wear your black hat
and you try to attack website
and you get in to the mind set
of the attacker and then, of
course, we go to defense where
you know how to apply the best
set of techniques to protect
your website and you really
understand what is the mechanism
or how you can apply them
successfully and for some of
those things, especially for
hacking we will cover
investigation and give you some
puzzle and interesting hacks to
look and understand if you can
figure them out.  One of the
essential challenges we had to
overcome     come     come was
it is not easy to teach web
security because you manipulate
useable code.  We can't put it
online and how you do that?  You
oshlgly people    ep
ly    originally people come up
with the idea of use ing virtual
machine and you have to run
things.  This is not very ideal
bau it is           because it
is very resource intensetive.
It is on your computer and
limits the amount of device you
can use.  So about a year ago we
were thinking of a problem and
we say well, what technology has
so much evolved.  Let's try to
do something different.  Let's
try to use a web hack technology
and the crazy idea we had let's
br    build a web server in to
the Web page.  I know that
sounds crazy but the idea was we
have sweb service
web service worker.  We can make
it intercepting a request and
respond to that.  And let's
throw in a web SQL in
database and see if it works.
We try ied it and it works real
ly now.  Now what we have for
you is a test bed where you just
go to the website and then
everything happens to your
browser, nothing to install.
You get --    so it is very easy
ands  it is       all happens
as you aren a real website.
That being said this is our
world and you want to show -- to
see it?  Yes?
>>
(Applause.) Can
ELIE BURSZTEIN:  Let's jump
to the first demo that will show
you the framework.  So we are
going to do a simple website
which going through logging our
users.  So it    to do that we
are going to first need to have
a server system.  As everything
and really look like with
express.  We recognize syntax.
We need to declare our world.
When you log-in page we need
would       two pages.  We need
somewhere where the user will
land and we have a form.  Let's
create that.  And then let's add
a second which would be process
ing information and decide
whether or not you try to log in
.  So we are going to create two
words.  One is a get and the
other one is (inaudible) and for
now which is going to say LOL
just to see if it works.
Remember this always -- you can
see it on the bar.  This is all
across.  No connection.  All off
line.  And we hope it is going
to work.  All right.  So let's
look the other side, we load the
framework and go to the page
and see if it works.
And here you have it.  We have a
working Web page in to our
browser.  Now let's add a little
bit more things because it is a
log-in page.  So we need a form
.  Add a form.  Unfortunately
Fortunately
support templates like any
normal web form.  Let's add --
password and a log in fee and
let's reload to make sure we see
our log in form
.
>> Hole on Hold on.
ELIE BURSZTEIN:  To add the
template, I fore -- we have to
add the indexing and we are
going to load the template and
we load -- and mopefully you
have
hopefully you have a nice GUI
layer form.  That's great.  It
didn't do much.  We need to
process it.  So let's have a
bunch of users.  So here what we
are going to do is we are going
to add a database.  So adding a
database in the framework is
very uz    easy.  All you have
to do is create a database one
line of code, do automatic for
us.  And then we are going to
add a user, so let's create a
user table which just contain a
log and password.  All right.
Let's add a user, Google user
for the demo.  And by the way,
do not store your password.  Do
not do this.  This is a demo.
This isn't secure.  So let's add
that and add a little bit of
Java code to check where
database and collect if it
happened.      ed
check if it happen
ed.  Run it in to a SQL query
and test if it is correct and we
have you had everything
should
have everything.  Let's try it.
Reload.  Now we have a page.
Let's try with a wrong password.
So Google I/O A password 1, 2,
.  Yes.  User network and works
as intended and try again.
Google I/O as a cuesor
user.  And password and click on
it.  Whoo hoo we are logged in.
So we have a fully functional
log in system with database
website few lines of code.  This
is a form we built
framework we built and
this is the framework that we
used to create a cherz      n
exercise.  Yes?
(Applause.)
ELIE BURSZTEIN:  All right.
Let's go back to the slide and
talk a little bit more about the
contents.  So we show the
technical framework we have
behind it.  Framework is great.
Content is better.  You need it
.  So laets jum           let's
jump in to one of the SQL
injection and show you what kind
of content you will learn.  You
can attack from
Attack that you can suffer
from.  And how to prevent them
and after that Yuan will do a
few exercises of how you can
learn it hands off.  So why do
SQL injections exist?  During
our little demo we introduced a
vulnerability           ner
nerability.  Because when you
have a SQL statement and skl
contains both key words which
tell you what to do and
parameter will tell you what to
look for.  If attacker is to
control one of the parameters
you can inject key words and the
server have no way to
distinguish between two the and
we have this any verse in
universe in our
very own code.  It make injeblgt
ion         jeksion possible.
Attacker with basis control
skwool query  er       SQL
SQL query will bypass
any security check you have.
And delete ing the database
encrypting it and do other
things.  Norm      Formally the
consequences of an attack, it
brinls        brijs
bridges confidential yt and also
ity       ity and it
authenticate without knowing the
password.  You can defeat any
type of check.
So there is really type of SQL
injection.  Classic one we are
going to demonstrate one today
and there is more advanced one
and second sword       order
injection and the blind
injection.  So the class can one
as I explained works very
simply the attacker instead of
sending what you expect, will do
the unexpectible and try to
manipulate the SQL query by send
ing specific payloads and you
your data business will happy
ily do whatever wants and here
is a concrete example.  Right?
If the attacker can inject the
user name then he can decide and
say user name to say say gooeg
Google allege        then
and then close the field
and add dash dash and which --
you can see on the screen well,
you are basically bypassing
authentication.  So to make it
more concrete let aets     's
jump to our second demo.  We
will show the attack live
hopefully.  Demo, please.
All right.  So with that
tsh we are        --        --
we are back to our demo.  Can
you going ba to the code, if you
remember we put the user name
and put it in to our query.  You
can see it on the  he screen.
We user input and be able to log
to the website without the
password.  So let's demonstrate
that.  So the way to do that is
as we explained is you use user
nim.         r  r name.  And
then instead of doing what
expected we are going to add a
quote to close the parameters
and then we are going to escape.
And the -- escape and SQL is
just this.  How many of thinking
it goes      going to work?
One person.  You have no faith m
in moo          in me.  We are
going to do it.  Let's try.  All
right.  So here it is.  We will
log to website without any
password because we let the
attacker manip put lay
ulate the input which you should
never do.  Go back to the slide
.  Is how do you prevent that?
There is a simple way to defend
against that.  This is called
parameterized query and also
known as prepared statement.
Instead of use ing the value
able in to your query you are
going to write a query and
specific what is the pa ra
rameter should do and then
put in afterwards.  That will
prevent SQL injection and you
should escape the user input.
You should not trust them.  Such
.    So that concludes our
short demo of SQL inject shub
ion.  We are going to show
you how the exercise
works and how the frameworks
works.  How many of you would
like to get early access to the
course.  That's brilliant.  All
of you.
YUAN NIU:  All right.  So
so signing up is very easy.  You
have to register use ing the
link on the screen starting
today.  G.co/learnwebtech.
Let's switch to the demo mow
mo   mo.  Since we are
familiar with SQL injection
already we are kept      skip to
that.  As I willy mentioned
each        ed             ly
Elie mentioned each top
ic   ic   ic   ic   ic will have
material and quizzes and, of
course, the exercises that are
going to give you some hands-on
experience so that you can
reinforce what you have been
learning.  You will be attacking
defending and investigating
sites and to make it a little
more fun we are take ing
inspiration from the power
versus cake more to kraPt
vaft      draft some of your
scenarios.  In our world the pi
sin ate         inned Kate is
sind Kate is a
syndicate is a
little worry ied.  They are
going to try to attack the rival
's website.  So we will be tick
steking with the base ic
exercises today and since we
have pretty much done attack No.
1 with Elie we will skip to No.
2 and for this I will need my
black hat.  Okay.  All right.
So we have an objective on the
left.  Hey pie, that cake shop
is still in business.  We can't
keep lose ing slices of our
territory to rival industries.
They still have a most on   ly
online operation for now but we
must acts quickly.  They are
still vulnerable to skwg
SQL injections.  We have gotten
a leaked copy of their server
owed code but               code
but no idea who the user could
be.  We need to you get their
customer list and get to it.  Pi
boss.  So very hopefully we
have a direct link to the page
that we are going to attack.
And we have a copy of the server
code.  So we have the same
vulnerable
ner    nerability as before but
because we don't know the user
name
we -- our previous bad input
won't work.  So let's take a
look at the code.  And on    on
line 12 we see that actually it
doesn't really matter what the
select statement returns as long
as it returns anything at all.
So this is where we will be
targeting our new traft
crafted query.  We need to get
the where statement to return
true ats all times.  And to do
that, we will just add let's
see,
1 equals 1 and this has an
affect of saying choose --
select from users where user
name equals admin or true.  And
so now we are going to force the
statement to true and now we
have access to their customer
list.  And that popup means that
we succeeded.  So we can move
on to the defense.  Okay.
Close this
.  Okay.  For this I'm back on
to cake.  And I have got my
white hat for that.  So our
mission once again greetings
fellow baker.  As you know this
one chatter of an upstart pie
maker with crusty connections.
We spP     suspect they have
been trying to attack cake shops
.  Your site has been identify
ied as one of these targets.
In particular it seems log-in
page leaves vulnerable to SQL
injection.  Please fix it at
your earliest con convenience
cake boss.  So this time we are
going to use the editor and
let's see, I'm going to refresh.
Let's see, oops.  Refresh
again.  Sometimes the server
need o to get updated properly.
So it takes a little bit of
time.  Okay.  There we go.  And
let's verify first that we are
still vulnerable to the SQL
injection attack.  And indeed we
are.  Okay.  So all right.  We
are going to use our edit tore
or to fix things and this
editor comes with hiring, all
the nice stuff.  And we are also
need these three buttons on the
side.  The first one will run
our code against the test
framework and make sure that
what we are doing will succeed,
will not succeed and just tells
us when we finish the exercise.
And in this case we failed
because we haven't actually fix
ed anything.  The second button
is going to give us a hint.  And
finally the third one will re
set everything and sosh
sdosh that we can rt
-- so that we can
start from scratch.  To go about
actual tli fixing    ing
ly fixing this we will
use parameterized query ies and
has     has     it is lot called
a prepared statement.  We are
not spelgs        supposed to
use user input directly we will
sell the tell the SQL prepare a
statement that has specify ied
exactly when to expect external
input.  So here this is the
parameterized statement and then
give it the user name A.    and
password here.  Let's see,  if
that passes our test.  Okay.  So
there       this should be
good.  Let     Now let's refresh
and double check that we have
-- it actually works -- oops
.  And we have successfully be
defends ourselves against
this particular SQL attack.
Remember that is just the base
ic exercise.  In practice in
create ing actual websites in
the view it sanitizer s rs user
input.  Never trust external
input.  That's it for the demo
today.  Let's not tempt the demo
Gods any further.  Back to the
slides, please.
(Applause.)
YUAN NIU:  Okay.  So thank
you for attending our sense
session.  Even you can
sign up for act     early access
to the course which will be
released this summer and if you
are interested in learning more
about web tech or maps or
head haefr       over to some of
sandboxes.  Interest is
there                There is
one by stage 6 and thank you
again and enjoy the rest of I/O.
We will stick around for
questions.
(Applause.)
>>
Should we go down for questions
?
>> Hi. This is is one of
first       very first thing
that hacker start doing.  The
main problem with      what we
face is how that website gets
hacked and it keeps sending
e-mails to a thousand other
persons and we never knew until
website host actually what's --
brings down our host ser vefr
ver.  Do you know what is a
best practice to start sending
any kind of e-mail from one web
hosting server or I don't know
-- how do you like -- just a
suggestion for that.
ELIE BURSZTEIN:  There are
many of those.  One other thing
that we recommend is if you
don't need the mail function
ality to remove it from PHP as a
configuration level and also
add firewall --   s will deny
any connection to port 25.  If
you don't sending mail from your
code just prevent it at the
Linux or the operating system
level.
>> But you know, when we are
in a shared server, so maybe
like other users.  So the host
don't give the access to do that
.
ELIE BURSZTEIN:  I ginned
stand.
>> That's
I under
stand.  That's why it is hard.
No magic wand.  The best thing
is to disable the mail function
al yiment          al   ality if
you can.
YUAN NIU:  Keep an eye on
your logs and look for spikes in
traffic and that's usually the
first time      sign.
>> All right. Thank you.
>>
>>.
RAW FILE
GOOGLE I/O 2017
SAN JOSE, CALIFORNIA
MAY 18, 2017
5:30 P.M. CST
STAGE 3
USING GOOGLE CLOUD AND
TENSORFLOW ON ANDROID THINGS
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
1-877-825-5234
+001-719-481-9835
Www.captionfirst.com
This text is being provided in a
rough draft format.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART) is provided
in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
***.
>> Tennessee
sorFlow
>>
.
Bed     Sent      TensorFlow
>> Hi everyone. My name is
Sam Beder
and I'm a product manager on
Android things.  So I want to
talk about Google services on
Android things and adding these
services to the device and your
device's potential.  What I real
ly want to convince of you today
is not only Google services on
adestroyed things
Android things easy
and semless but it can make a
huge difference in the use cases
that you can put as well as for
your end users.  We have many
sessions on Android things as
well as demos in the sanld
sanldz        sandz
sandbox area and code labs for
you
to learn more things.  Many of
you are can being
come ing to this session with
ideas of devices that you want
to make on Android things or for
I/O  oT devices in general and
I want to show you today all the
compelling use cases pa that
you             that you can get
when you int skrit      egrate
some of these Google services.
So I'm going to go through a
number of services today.  First
I'm going to talk about Google
Play services which includes a
whole suite of tools such as the
mobile voois API
vision APIs, location services
as well as Firebase.  After that
I'm going to gooif       dive
in to Firebase
fire    Firebase in a little
more detail to show you how the
realtime data that Is
base that Firebase provides
can allow you to publish and
persistent data and events in
interesting ways.  After that
I'm going to in to TensorFlow
and how TensorFlow we think is
the perfect application of a
powerful
on device processing of your
Android things device to really
add intelligence to that device.
Next I want to talk about
Cloud Platform and how use ing
Google Cloud            Cloud
Platform I   you can train and
visualize and take action on
your device    ve   ve   vices
in the field be and I am going
to touch on the Google assist
ansz     ant and I   all the
things you can get.  Before I
dives in to services I am going
to quickly gefr      over things
.  A system on molled
module design.  This means that
we work really closely with our
silicon partners to bring you
modules which you can place
directly in to your IoT devices.
Now these modules are sech
such that it is economical to
put them in to devices when you
are make ing millions of device
s or if you have a very small
one or if you are prototype ing
device.  E   We had a session
earlier today specifically going
from Poe     prototype to
Android things and give you more
details and bring your devigs
vice to production on
Android things.  The Android
things separate ing   e ing
operating system a
placed on top of these modules.
So Android things is a new
vertical of Android built for
IoT devices.  Since we work so
closely with our silicon partner
s we are able to maintain these
modules in new ways.  It allows
these devices toor   be more
secure and update ible.  Also
since it is an Android vertical
you get all the Android APIs
they are used to for Android
development as well as the
developer tools and the Android
ecosystem.  In addition on
Android things we have added
some new APIs.  Such as
peripheral I/O and user driver
thatly   ly    allow to you
control                    to
you       llow you to control
the hardware     on   ware on
your device in different ways.
Really the queue       key piece
of Android things I believe is
the services on top.  Because of
the API surface that Android
things provides, it makes it
much easier for Google to put
our services on top of Android
things.  I say endless
possibility ies here because not
only does going gl
Google already support all the
services I'm going to walk you
through today, but any services
that Google makes in the future
will be much more portable on
Android things because of this
API service.
So now I start dive ing in to
some of these services let's guk
talk about Google Play
services and the useful tools
that it provides.  Google Play
services gives you access to a
skwooet         suite of tools
some of which you see here.  So
you get things like the mobile
vision APIs, which allow you to
leverage the in  Intel
intelligence in your Android am
camera, to identify people
in an image as well as faces and
their expressions.  You also
get the nearby APIs which lets
when you have two devices near
each other as those devices
interact with each other in
interesting ways.  You get all
the cast pooiP       APIs which
lets you from your Android
things device cast to a cast
enabled device swir
somewhere else.  Next you have a
location services, which lets
you query things like what are
the cafes near highway
me and what are their hours.
You also get the Google fit ain
APIs aallow you to attach
sentors         sensors to your
device and then visualize this
dethat as accept
that         data as steps or
other activity ies in interest
ing ways.  Finally you get
Firebase we will talk about more
in a minute.  Some of you might
know about CTS certification
and how CTS certification is a
necessary step in order to get
these Google Play services.
With Android things because of a
hardware model that I just talk
ed about, these modules actually
come precertified.  So they are
all pre-CTS certified meaning
ing    ing Google Play
services will work right out of
the box.  Gives have you
absolute                   you
you absolutely no work to
get those things on your Android
things devies.        vie
vie advice.  We also
vie    vice.  We have
a custom IoT variant of Google
Play services.  This allows us
to make Google Play services
more lightweight by take ing out
things like phone specific UI
elements and game libraries that
we don't think are relevant for
IoT devices.  We also give you
a signed out experience of
Google Play services.  So no un
authenticated APIs because these
just aren't relevant for many
IoT devices.  So now let's dive
in to Firebase in for detail.  I
want to walk you through one of
our code samples.  This is a
code sample for a smart doorbell
use ing fire because.  It
involve
e ing     ing
basement            e ing
ing fair        e ing     ing
Firebase.  So walk you through
this diagram.  On the left you
see a user interacting with the
smart doorbell.  What happens
they press the button on the
smart doorbell and l   the
camera takes a picture of
themmen   .  On the right there
is another user in the Android
phone they can use an app to
connect to a Firebase database
thatty can       y   can
retrieve that image in realtime.
So how does this work?  When
you press the button on the
smart camera and the camera
takes a picture of you.  Then
use ing the Android Firebase SDK
which use ing the Google place
services APIs all on the device
it sends this image to the
Firebase database in the cloud.
The user on the  he other
hand,               oer    he
other end can then use the exact
same Google Play services.
>> LIZ ANDERSON: Destroyed
Android Firebase SDK on
their phone and retrieve that
image.  In our code sample we
also send this image to the
cloud vision APIs to get
additional annotations about
what's in the image.  So these
annotations could be something
like in this image there is a
person holding a package.  So I
can give you an additional
context about what's going on.
It is pretty gool      cool.  If
you go and build this demo, you
can see when you press the
button and takes a picture, in
less than a second the picture
will appear and then a few
seconds later after the image is
propagate the through
d through the cloud vigs ape
s           vision APIs the
annotations will appear as well.
I want to walk through some of
the code that pushes this data
to Firebase.
So the first line you see here
is just krooe Kate ing   e
ing              create ing a
new door ring instance that we
are going to use in our Firebase
database.  Then all we need to
do to make this data appear in
our Firebase database is set the
appropriate fields of our door
ring instance.  So here you can
see in the highlighted portion
we are setting the time
time many P and the
stamp and the image fields
with the server time P stamp
stamp and l   the image
URL and the images  will appear
in a Firebase database to be
retrieve by    ed by the user on
the other side.  We send our
images to the cloud vision ape
APIs to get those annotations
.  So we do that by kaud
calling the cloud vision APIs
and then setting the appropriate
field for those and know teagss
and flow teags
notation so that
additional context will company
appears with       ass
well for the user  r
as well on the
user on the other en
oer    he other ind     end.  I
can't talk about all the Google
Play services.  So instead I
want to move on to ens
TensorFlow.  We really think
that TensorFlow is the perfect
application for the ondevice
processing of your Android
things device.  So as you have
heard from some of the previous
talks on Android things Android
things is not really well suited
if you are just make ing a
simple sensor.  To fully utilize
the and void droid things
Android
things Pratt       platform
there should be some
intelligence on this device.
You might wonder though if you
are make ing an Internet connect
ed device IoT device why do you
need this ondevice processing.
There is several reasons why
this could be really important.
One reason has to do with
bandwidth.  If, for example, you
are make ing a camera that's
counting the number of people in
a line, and you just care about
that number, only propagate out
that number you save huge
amounts on bhand       badged
band wit    width but
by not needing to send that
anywhere.  When you have br mit
intermittent connective
ity.  If your device is only
sometimes connected to the
Internet, for it to be really
functional it needs to have an
on deves   vice processing for
when it is offline.  The next
reason for ondevice processing
has too     to do with the
principle of least privilege.
So if you again have that camera
where you all you care about is
the number of people standing
in a line, by principle of least
privilege you should only be
propagate ing that number even
if you trust the other end where
you are sending it.  There is
also some regulatory reasons
where this could be important
for your use case.  The final
reason for ondevice processing
has to do with realtime
applications.  So if you are,
for example, make ing a robot
that has to navigate through an
environment, you want to have on
device processing.  So if
something comes in front of that
robot you will be able to react
to the situation.  Again I want
to mention that we have have
code lab for TensorFlow and
troin          .
>> LIZ ANDERSON: Destroyed
things and you can try it out in
code lab area or at home.  I
want to do a live demo so we can
really see how it works.
So what I have here it is a
pretty simple setup.  We have
one of our supported boards
which is a raspberry pie in this
case as well as a wut
button a camera and a speaker.
The button here is on top and
camera is located in this
Android head's eye.  And then
the speaker is in its mouth.
What what's going to happen is
when I press the button the
camera will take a picture.
That image is then sent through
a TensorFlow model located local
ly on the device and in the
speaker will then say what that
TensorFlow model thinks it saw.
So for you here today I have
various dog breeds.  Because
locally on this TensorFlow model
I have what's called the
inception model.  Now that
inception model is a model
provided by Google that's able
to identify thousands of objects
.  Include ing dog breeds.  So
let's see if we can do it.  I
just need to line up the image.
And.
>> I see a Dalmatian.
SAM BEDER:  All right.  For
those of you who couldn't see.
(Applause.)
SAM BEDER:  Yeah, .  It is
in fact, a Dalmatian.  But let's
do it one more time.    to show
you can do more than just one
dog breed.  So this time I have
a French bull dog.  All right.
Line it up again.  Hope for the
best.
>> Hey that bhooks
looks like me.  Just kidding.  I
see a French bull dog.  Rt
SAM BEDER:  All right.
Yeah, .
(Applause.)
SAM BEDER:  Good job little
guy.  So as I tension
mentioned this is already
all running locally.
This is not connected to the
Internet at all and this is
battery powered.  It is totally
portable.  So I think that this
example really shows some of the
power you can get with
TensorFlow.  Now it is walk
through some of the code that
makes this integrate ion
possible.  This first page as
you can see is pretty simple.
In    And this just shows um
load         up loading the
appropriate TensorFlow lie braeb
brary to be used by our
defies    vice.  The first thing
I want you to note here is that
we are actually only loading
the same libraries as is used by
Android.  So all the TensorFlow
code that works on Android will
also work on Android things.
All the samples that all you
have on Android for TensorFlow
you can port immediately to and
dried things
Android things.  The second
thing I want you to note is that
actually load in the inference
libraries of TensorFlow.
TensorFlow is basically composed
of two sets of libraries.
There is training, which is
where you give it thousands of
images along with labor bl
labels.  So you can make
that model that can make those
predictions and then there is
the inference libraries where
use ing that model   del that
you trained to theak       make
those predictions.  Let gaes to
many             's to the core
functionality.  These are the
steps to run input data through
a TensorFlow model.  The first
method you see there the feed
method is we are loading in your
input data.  So we have three
arguments.  Inpull     pull
put layer name which is the
first layer of TensorFlow model
where you are going to put your
input data and next there is
tensordy vengs
dy imensions which describes the
structure of your input layer
so you you can understand what's
going in to your mod did    el
and then you have iment imagine
pixels
which is
the                 cks
imagine pick
sells
im    have image pick sells
pixels.  The input
data is pixels.  But this same
type of tense TensorFlow model
will work across many use cases.
So if instead you had just
sensor data or a combination of
sensor data and camera data, you
could use the same type of
TensorFlow model and it would
still work.  So the next slide,
the actual highlighted portion
is really actual work gets done.
So we call the one method.  To
run this input data through our
TensorFlow model to get that
retriks         prethikion
dikion on t
prediction on the other side.
Finally we need a fetch our data
so we can use it.  We call
fetch along with output array to
store our data.  Now this out
put array is composed of
elements that correspond to the
confidence that an object is
what we saw on the image.  So in
our first example we predicted
Dalmatian.  That means that the
element         and     element
with highest confidence was that
that core y e y   re
corresponded to Dalmatian.  For
example, if there is two results
that both were highly
confidence            confident
you could say, I think it is one
of these two things.  And if
there were no results -- there
is no results above a certain
threshold of conferred
confidence you can say I don't
know what's in in image.  Once
you have output of confidences
you can do extra gePd depend
genldzing on       ing
depending
ing    ing us       ing    ing
your use case but I think there
is more zing    ing     interest
ing things that we can do.  Once
we connect devices like this to
the cloud.  So next I want to
talk about Google Claude
platform                 Cloud
Cloud Platform and
specifically cloud IoT core.  So
cloud IoT core is a new offer
ing that we are anouns     nows
nnounce ing here at I/O for
connecting IoT devices to the
Cloud Platform.  It has a number
of services.  You can do thing
likes      s like MQTT, MQTT is
a looit       lightweight fro to
kol that                 proto
kwol        to   tocol.  Card de
coder is 100% managed service.
It get things like automatic
load balance ing and resource
propositioning
position              pre
positioning and you can connect
one device of cloud IoT core or
a million devices and all these
things still work the aim
same way.  Global access point,
no matter what region your
device is in you can use the
same configure ation and connect
to the same Google Cloud.
Cloud
I.D.      oishgs T          IoT
wof     cores  -- -- you can
configure individual devices
that you have in the field as
well as control those devices
set up alerts and set out role
level access controls.  Allowing
one user to be able to have
read and write access over a set
of devices.  And another user
to could only have one read
access or a subset of those
devices.  So as I mentioned
cloud IoT core connects you to
all the benefits of Google
platform.  This diagram shows
you a bunch of benefits that
Cloud Platform provides and I'm
not going to go through all of
them but just to point out a few
.  You get things like big query
and big table that allow you to
input all the data that you are
gathering from your Android
things devices and visualize and
query over that data.  You also
get cloud ML to make even more
complicated machine learning
models with based on alling the
data you that that you have
collected use ing the power of
the cloud.  Finally you get all
the Analytics tools that Cloud
Platform provides to visualize
and sample alerts on your data
and take action on the devices
out in the field.  So understand
these Analytics a little bit
befrt       Bert      better I
want to go through one more demo
.  This demo is running live in
our sandz box area
sanldz        and
sandz box area.  We have set up
a bunch of environmental
stations running on Android
things and sped      spread them
around campus.  Now -- bunch of
sensors on them.  Things like
humidity sense Sr.     or, tem
per tir,     ature, motion
detection and then we are able
to add all of this data in the
cloud by connecting it through
cloud IoT core.  You can see
some of the data from some of
these devices that are the ing a
gre gait and also
e ing a           the
aggregate.  You can also dive in
to one specific device to see
more data on what's going on
with that device as well as more
time series data on how that
device is performed over time.
You might notice though that
this demoef shows you really
well that you can connect these
de advices to Google Cloud but
it doesn't really utilize the on
device processing that I talk
ed.  I want to go over a few
more examples that show you
these two services working
together.  Because when you
combine TensorFlow and Google
Cloud            Cloud Platform
you can do some amazingly power
ful things.  So my first example
kind of extends this
environmental station demo that
I just walked you through.
Imagine instead of just putting
in environmental stations around
, we actually connected them to
a smart vending machine.  We
were then able to use all the
input data from our
environmental station to have a
machine learning model use ing
TensorFlow running locally on
this device.  You could predict
things like supply and demand
based on vendzing machines'
environment and optimize when
this vendzing machine would be
restocked.  You could also
connect all vented        vend
ing machines to the cloud and do
even more complicated analysis
on those vendzing machines.  You
can do inventory analysis to
figure out which items are
performing best in which
environmenteds.  And
environments and you
do even better prediction models
based on all the the data you
are collects ing.  This is a
perfect example to do what we
call federated learning.  So
federate ing   e ing    d learn
ing is when we have multiple
machines that are alling able to
learn role      locally but
based on those local learning we
can aggregate that data to make
even better machine learning
ing    ing model in the cloud.
So here you can imagine having
one vendzing machine in a school
and another vending machine in
a stayed yument          dium
and both vending machines would
have very personalized models
based on their environment.  But
also both benefit from each
other bying a gref gait      gre
ing a      ing a
gre gaiting their data in cloud
and there is a good example that
shows you can do spr
interesting things without a
camera.  But my next example
goes over a camera use case.
Because I think that cameras are
perfect applications for doing
some of this on device process
ing.  So imagine you have a
grocery store and the grocery
store puts up cameras to count
the number of people standing in
line.  This camera would use a
TensorFlow model that's lobing
locally able to count
that number of peep elt in the
image and propagate that number
to the cloud.  You could use
this data to open the optimal
number of registers at any given
time.  So you never have to
wait in line at the grocery
store again.  With all of your
aggregated data you also do more
complicated machine learning
models.  You could predict how
many people you should staff at
your groer ri          grocery
store ain the         at any
given day and the differences
between grocery stores.  You
could be useful for the shoppers
, the end users.  You could
imagine make ing a mobile app
where at home you can check how
long the gresh grocery store
line is so you are never fruf
straighted   ed
fru straighted   ed
frustrated by having to
wait in line.  The next use case
I want to go over is the
broadens this camera cam Pell a
example a little bit
more and apply ies it to an
industrial use case.  So imagine
we have a factory that makes pi
zas and we add a camera that's
able to do quality control to
increase both the quality and
the efficiency for this
industrial application.  I
should note that we have another
talk that's specifically on
enterprise use cases on Android
things.  So we should listen to
that talk if you want to know
more about what's possible on
Android things for some of these
industrial applications.  So in
this case we would have a
TensorFlow model that's locally
ability           ly   ly able
to learn how to ePt     accept
and reject pi.
>> zzas by koint
koument         kounltd
ing the number of toppings of
each pizza.  Most of them we
will see how have six tomatoes
and five olives.  So they are
accepted and we will come to one
that has too     two,      too
many tomatoes -- too few toe
mays and too           ea
mate toes and too few olives and
we reject that pizza.  You can
do more analysis such      such
as strak       track our through
put and flag if our error rate
goes above a certain tlesh holds
hreshold.  One more
use case I want to go over that
uses machine learning in a
slightly different way.  So
that's going to be reiners
in   inforcement learning apply
ied to an agricultural use case
.  So imagine we have a field
that has a bunch of moisture
sensors in the ground as well as
spin sprin               l
sprinklers and these are all
connected to a central hub run
ning and groid         Android
things.  This hub could do some
machine learning to optimize
exactly what the output of when
and how much water each sprinkle
r should output to optimize our
crop growth.  You may have
haerdz of DeepMind, as a company
at alphabet that recently made
Alpha ge   Go but this used
re-enforce         en   en   en
enP    en   eniners      in
en    iners      inforce
ment learning.  It an amazing
tool that be used on Android
things really well.  With
reinforcement learning you
discover sod nuanced use cases
such as imagine your hill had a
hill on it.  And in in    that
case you may want to water the
crops at the bot tonl of the
tom of the hill less
than those at the top of the
hail      hill because the sfrin
kelt            rin
sprinklers the a the tomb of the
hill                        top
of the hill might have runoff
water.  Android things makes
integrations things like that
seamless and provides you the
tools to do anything that you
imagine.  I think that use ing
things like TensorFlow and cloud
together can also do some real
ly amazing use cases that you
can't do with just one.  Kwin
Combine ing these services
could do so much more four
for your device and end users.
There is one more service I
want to talk about today and
that's the Google asaves
ssistant.  So Android things
supports the Google assistant
ant    ant SDK.  There was a
huge number of use cases that we
think that assistant can do for
you.  Apply    llows you to
connect to all the knowledge of
Google as well as allows you to
control the devices in your home
.  Again we have a co    code
lab that goes over getting
Android things to worning
work with the Google assist
anlt     ant.  You can do it at
home or in our sandbox area.
We partnered with AIY which is a
group at Google that makes kits
for do it yourself artificial
intelligence makers.  What you
see on the screen here is the
kit that they recently released
which is the Voice kit which is
one of the easiest ways that you
can get started with and droigs
droid things working
with the Google ahh cystant
ant              assistant.  I
want to go over one more feature
of Android things and that's
the Android things developer
console.  The Android things
developer console brings all
these services together.  Tr
It is our new developer portal
that lets you add all these
thvrgs        services to your
device in a really simple way.
The key with the Android things
developer console is
customization.  You get all the
ult mealt coal of
imate control of what services
will go on your device.  You
also get device management and
jum dates           updates.
Allows you to create your
projects as wills       well as
upload your own APKs and push
fees tee          those feature
updates to the device in the
field.  The also where you get
all the updates from Google.  So
these are the security updates
and the feature updates that
will make your devices secure
.  Sichbs you            Sibs
Since you get cotal
tal        cotal    tal
total control.  Believe the
custom meags of the
ization of the developer console
gives you the control to create
anything that you can imagine.
A lock     n unlocking this
limited potential of what we
think is possible of Android
things especially when combined
with Google services.  So the
to summarize things
Android things gives that
platform that makes hardware
development feasible.  It gives
all the Android APIs to make the
development process easy,
combined with the system on
module design to make it quick
and economical to make a
prototype and also bring that
device to production.  But the
services on top I believe are
the huge factsor that allows to
innovate and enhance your device
as well as bring new features
to your users.  So Google Play
services which twi     gives you
the tweet of              the
suite of tools location services
as well as Firebase.  You get
TensorFlow which us use the
powerful on device processing of
your Android things device to
add that intelligence to your
device.  You also get Cloud
Platform and specifically cloud
IoT core to connect your device
to the even greater intelligence
of the cloud.  And finally you
get the Google ahh cystant
ant              assistant the
latest and greatst  est in
Google's personal assistant tech
nology.  All these haveses is
services and anything
that comes in the future will
fit     fit on top of Android
things.  I want to leave you
with      tud with my call to
action.  We have huge number of
session         sessions on
Android things this year and
demos and code labs to learn
more of what's Bob     possible
on Android things.  We have a
developer site to download the
latest Android image and start
make ing your idea.  I encourage
you to add some these Google
devices         services to your
device to see how powerful this
can be.  Tell us about it.
Join our developer community
where thousands of people are
already asking questions share
ing their ideas, share ing
their prototypes and getting
feedback.  Again I'm Sam Beder
and I look forward to hearing
about all the amazing devices
that you are building on Android
things that             things
that intd great these
int great that's
integrate these
powerful Google services.  Thank
you.
(Applause.)
SAM BEDER:  I think I have
a few minutes for questions if
anyone wants to come up to the
microphones
.
>> Hardware and (Off
microphone).  Do you have a --
(Off microphone).
SAM BEDER:  So you mean --
(Off microphone)
.
>>
so much, for coming to the smart
home talk.  The goal here is
really to give you guys a little
bit of understanding and
background on how do you connect
to IOT device to Google
Assistant so you can allow that
device to be controlled by the
Google Assistant.  I'm Mark Spai
ts, the product lead for smart
home and the Google Assistant.
This is David Shyer, kind of my
partner in crime.  He is the
engineering lead for the Smart
Home Google Assistant.  I think
when you start to look at some
of the things that are happening
in this space, it's really
clear that having assistant-
controlled physical space is
going to be extremely important
moving forward.  So when we
start to look at Smart Home and
Google Assistant, it was clear
this was a feature we had to
have when Google Home launched
last year.  The feature has
become a pillar of the Google
Home experience and what YUZers
come to expect when they're
interacting with the Assistant.
The other thing is the IOT
market which you guys have heard
a thousand times, it's one of
the biggest buzz words of the
last three years, it's actually
finally happening, and the
assistants are part of that, the
interaction with these devices.
So for us, we knew there's a
unique opportunity for the
Google Assistant as relates to
the Smart Home space.
Just basic numbers.  These are
numbers you've seen a thousand
times.  IoT is going and there's
a thousand devices.  I want to
look at 2017.  There's 8.4
billion connected devices, and
out of that, you have 5.2 that
are actually consumer segmented
devices.  It's huge.  This means
that having that physical thing
in the space that's connected
to the cloud is actually a big
enough penetration rate that
having just to control it
actually makes sense to a user.
And those devices are super
diverse, right.  You have things
from cars and lights and fans
and robot vacuums.  I just got a
connected machine delivered to
my desk so I could test my
barbecue this weekend.  That's
how far we've come.  Everything
will be connected and if it's
connected, it should be
controlled at some level by the
Assistant.  The next thing that
we really start to look at is
where does the Assistant play in
this user interaction?   For
us, it was always, the Assistant
will be at the center of these
intelligent interactions with
these IoT devices.  And we put
the word "intelligent" in there
for a specific reason.  Today, a
lot of the ways that we control
these things are simple on and
off switches.  They're actually
not intelligent.  It's simply an
on and off command and the
thing goes on and off, but it
doesn't take into consideration
context, device type, and all
these things that a user would
come to expect.
Which got us to this point in
our development, and we said,
it's about conversations, and
not about demands, and this is a
core philosophy that our team
looks at and we make product
decisions and engineering
decisions based on this
philosophy.  A user should be
able to say multiple things to a
device, right, not just turn
this device on.  But if you look
at a light and all the vast
commands you can give it, just
to simply control it, it's
amazing, so you can change the
color, you can turn them on and
off, you can do things like make
the bedroom brighter.  Imagine
yourself sitting there with your
spouse, your roommate or your
best friend.  Think about all
the ways that you tell that
person to turn the light on or
control the light.  It's
extremely different, if you're
talking to your mom versus your
girlfriend versus your boyfriend
.  All these things we need to
be able to understand so we can
do what the user wants.
So to do this, we had to get
context.  We had to understand
things like what is in the home?
What are the rooms in the
home?   Who is in the home?
This is the key reason our team
decided to create the Google
Home graph.  The Google Home
graph stores and provides the
convectual data about the
devices in the homes to the
Google Assistant.  Now, this may
sound very similar.  You've
heard these things, right,
there's knowledge graph, a graph
for this, a graph for that.
But, actually, the home is one
of the last frontiers.  If you
look at yourself in your day-to-
day, if you walk out of here, we
pretty much know that you've
got a mobile phone, this is your
GPS locations, and this is
where you are.  As soon as you
walk in the home, a lot of us
know that you walked in the home
, but we have no idea what
happens after that.  Are you in
the living room?   Bedroom?
Watching TV?   Your phone may be
in the basement and you may be
upstairs.  We have to have a
contextual understanding of the
home to have a good experience.
graph really quickly.  We look
at it as properties, and there's
kind of three big sets of
properties and a lot of things
that kind of build upon these
properties.  So there's a
structure.  That structure has
an address.  It has managers, it
has rooms, it has labels.  Do
you have rooms?   Because rooms
are very specific.  What I do in
the bedroom and what I do in
the living room, saying the
exact same thing could mean
totally different in the context
.  So you have to understand
where you actually are in the
home.  And there's devices.
Devices are extremely unique,
and we have to know what type of
device is it, what are the
capabilities of the device?
What are the attributes?
What's the current state?   And
the reason is, there are
situations like this.  Let's go
back to my example.  If you're
sitting on the couch and you say
"dim the lights in the living
room a little bit."  That's a
super complex command or
conversation to even have with
someone sitting right next to
you.
Using the home graph, this is
what we first
do.  We say "are there any
lights in the living room?"
Basic question, yes, there are
lights in the living room.  Okay
.  Are the lights on?   Yes,
they're on, that's awesome.
What are they set to?   Oh,
these lights are on and set to
50 percent.  What does "a little
bit" mean?   In this case, "a
little bit" may mean 3%.  It's a
default thing we put in there.
We support things like little
bit, a lot, our interns put "a"
hella" in there because they're
from California.  We take that
data, package it up, and pass it
to the Google Assistant and the
assistant says, all right, got
it.  I will change these lights
from 50% to 53%.  That's how the
data from home graph is
actually being used in real
time.
But it was awesome as we were
building this, and we were
saying to ourselves, I think we
stumbled upon what's going to un
lock this market for everyone
when it comes to controlling
devices in the house.  So we
have to get this to
developers.  How do we allow
developers to build interactions
that leverage Google Assistant
in the home graph?   So today,
I'm really excited to introduce
smart-home Apps.  Smart-Home
Apps is an experience that you
can build using actions on
Google.  I'm sure you guys have
heard tons of actions about
Google.  It's my favorite
platform Google has made.  But
it's going to be the way that we
go from this being an adaptive
platform to everyone in the
audience being able to hook up
to the assistant, leverage the
home graph and control it in a
very conversational way.
But that's enough about me
talking.  I think most of you
want to see how do you actually
build one of these things, and
with that, I'll turn it over to
David to give you guys a
developer experience.
>> David: thanks, mark.
[applause].  as mark said, most
of you have.
>> probably seen actions on
Google right now.  it's our new
platform to let you extend the
assistant directly to your
applications, to your services,
and in this case, to your
hardware.  so we brought -- with
this launch, we're bringing
smarthome devices into the
actions on Google platform.  you
register the devices to the
home graph, and rather than
having the actions on Google
model where you talk to your App
, you change the voice, you can
have direct actions that
directly communicate with your
devices and everything else in
the home.  if you have lights,
you register to the in the
living room.  It turns on your
lights and other vendors' lights
.  It works seamlessly.  It's
the descriptive grammar that
lets the user interact.  No one
lights a light bulb that asks
too many questions so our system
is designed
for one-shot single actions, if
I don't forget, everything just
works.  How do we do this?   So
you guys, the folks that are
building hardware, building
smart-home devices, light bulbs,
thermostats, micro waves,
sprinklers, you're building
hardware.  We make it really
easy to build great hardware.
You provide a light-weight
infrastructure on top of what
you're already doing.  You've
got cloud control on top of
these devices.  Add in some
basic integration protocols.
All of these are stock, trivial
stuff implemented and we can add
on top of that all of the stuff
that Google is good at, the
natural language understanding,
the speech generation, the
personality, the home      home
graph Mark talked about, INTRT
ization, context, management,
and all of these complex schemas
of what does it mean to be a
washing machine and how do users
interact with washing machines?
We apply our learning to
these engines so they keep
getting better and everything we
improve you get the
improvements on as well.
We basically integrate in
two ways.  We have a flow for
device setup and a flow for
execution.  This is a setup flow
.  Very simple.  Once you have
registered, I want to show you
all of this end to end.  Once
you've registered, you simply --
your App shows up in our list
of smart-home Apps and the user
clicks on it.  Woe send them off
to you for registration.  Send
it back to us, give a request
for the devices.  Any data you
want, it's a simple protocol.
They have 17 lights that are
called these things in these
rooms, and they have these
traits associated with them and
what have you.  That's a full
sync each time.  You don't need
to do Delta management.  We do
that for you.  We take each
thing and put it in the home
graph.  Then in execution time,
we use our assistant stack to do
all the heavy lifting.  We've
gotten your state from your
devices.  We know what those
things are called and what the
capabilities are.  We field that
into our real-time speech
recognition engine.  If the
users named their light
something weird, we understand
it.  If it's chandelier American
gazebo, it understands it.  The
language knows it, and the
smart-home engine knows it.  All
of that stuff that lets us
build the query semantics we
give you, give those to you, do
your tasks, simple stuff, re
generate the text response and
speech response to the user, and
it works.
We have built some basic device
types.  We're building a lot
more over the coming weeks and
months.  Traits are where
functionality occurs.  You have
a simplest trait ever, on and
off.  This device has a switch.
Those traits then are made of
attributes, states and commands.
On and off is pretty simple.
No attributes.  One state.  I
bet you can guess what it is.
Pretty much one command that
just is turning things on and
off.  That trait then can be
composited into whatever devices
you want to make.  Right now,
we've launched publicly, those
are lights and switches and
thermostats and the like.  You
build a robot, you can reuse
that trait and make your robot
have an on-off trait.  Generally
speaking, all your robots
should have an on-off trait,
highly recommended, otherwise
problems occur.  So you'll be
able to build as we have more
and more traits, you can
composite your own device types,
whatever you want.  Maybe it's
a clock radio with clock and
radio functionality and all of
that stuff.  Maybe it's a robot
that combines custom traits you
have, traits we build and custom
traits that you can build on
top of this platform.  I'm going
to walk through the demo.  It's
really simple.  I want to do
this in six steps.  Register
your project on Google platform.
We'll set up alof.  We'll
alignment the smarthome App.
We'll use the gactions command
tool to test that package.  Once
you do that, you go to the real
App, production level, nothing
special, production level
assistant App, in-home control,
connect to your App, set up your
devices and start talking to
them.
So let's start the demo.
This is the actions on Google
Console.  This is the new con
sole we launched yesterday.  I'm
going to create a project, give
it some name.  Doesn't really
matter.  For here, I'm going to
call it Sheep Project.  See if
it lets me do that.
This will take a few seconds.
What we're doing is creating the
projects inside the Google
system, assigning a project ID
giving you the tools you need.
You may have seen the API
discussions we had earlier today
.  Actually, today, we are not
using APIAI for the SmartHome
stuff, because we've written all
the grammar.  You don't need to
write any grammar for these
actions.  We provide it for you.
Actions SDk, we skip leading
the docs, because we're
developers, and let's go and set
up the App information.  A lot
of the stuff on this page,
honestly, we don't need for home
automation for SmartHome
projects, but we will anyway
because the application wants it
.  For example, the assistant
voice, because everything you do
here runs as a native Google
App, it's running native
understanding, we can use the
natural voice.  We don't need to
change the voice.  So we'll
just say home control demo, full
description, demo, we don't
really care.  Category, let's
click "home control" down here
at the bottom, and what did I
miss, to control some stuff.
Obviously, when you do this for
real, since eventually, this
will be building in your
registry item, you'll want real
text there.  It's asking for
icons, same thing.  I'm going to
load up some dummy ones.  And
eventually, these will be used
when you submit your App.  Away
we go.  Testing instructions we
can skip.  It is called Sheep
Company.  Let's not think about
this too hard.  And feel free to
spam me there.  Privacy policy.
Just a dummy UR
L for now.
Great.  We've now created our
project.  One more thing to do,
number 2 on that list, account
linking.  So let's add account
linking.  Authorization code.
Let me go and grab my keys here.
These are keys in the demo App
we have put on the hub.  Please
do not use.  These are our keys
in your actually App.  I should
not have to tell you why.
I'm going to set this up, stock
, right off the shelf.  So I'm
not doing anything funky.  Test,
instructions, demo.
OLOF should now be set up.
Over here, this is our stock
example App, and all I'm going
to do is start this App and
standard proxy SSL stuff, so
start this running now.  Away we
go.  Now, when I load this, I
should be able to go
here and please don't hack into
my demo while I'm doing it.
There.  Now, this is a -- I know
, I shouldn't have said that.
You're doing it now.  I know I'm
not crazy.  It's one of you.
This is our example App.  We've
used this App for testing out
the application.  These are
virtual lights.  We use this in
our own development.  I can't
get 100 light bulbs at my desk,
people complain so we need to do
virtual testing.  Turn them on
and off and set them up for
cloud registration.  Now I have
an App running.  My next step,
I'm going to hop over here and I
am going to find the action.
We have this gactions command
here, which simply
-- woops -- this takes the
action -- actually, before I do
that, let me show you the action
package.  So you may have seen
action packages in other demos
that have lots and lots of other
stuff in them.  Ours is really
simple.  That's all it is.  You
put the URL at use of execution
in there, execution of sync,
everything else is stock.  And
then I can run this and go and
grab my project ID, which
happens to be easily right here.
And if I didn't forget
something because I'm on stage,
I can do that.  Of course it
asks me to update when I'm on
stage because Apps know when I'm
on stage.  Skip that.  Push the
App and now, it should be live.
I'm going to go over to the
phone.  Here on the phone, we
start the Assistant.  Go into
settings.  Home control.  I have
no devices.  There is my App.
So my App I just created and ran
is now available just like all
of our production partners here.
Click on that App, and
-- what we should probably see
-- woops -- yeah, yeah, yeah.
If we did that right, I've got
my devices, and these fill
lights that I put up here are
now available on the phone.  I'm
going to skip them because I'm
not going to cover that right
now, and I can say -- go back to
the Assistant, "turn on all my
lights."
All right.  Two of those
decided to get knocked off the
cloud.
Turn on all of my lights.
[applause]
>> Make my lights green. So
pretty simple stuff.  We have
lots of other device types,
thermostats, more complex things
.  This is the base case, and
you saw, yes, I did cheat.  We
have a little instance over here
, but that's all it takes.  So
with that, I will turn it back
to Mark.
>> Awesome. Great demo, David.
[applause].
So you go and crush it like
David just did, build your stuff
in like 36 hours and you're
ready to go but there's still a
couple of more things you have
to do to launch it.  Get a
device, because I have to test
it.  But then once you send the
device over to Google and you de
ploy your action, we will then
do a certification process.  And
the certification process is
really simple.  We do have a few
testers go through, test basic
things,alatency,     ence
late      latency, check
the privacy, and say, all right,
this is good, it's rate to go
into production, certify it and
launch it into production.  It's
a really simple process.  We
are making sure that the
experience that the end user is
getting is really good so that's
where the certification process
comes in, just to make sure
things like the right grammars
work and the right expectations
around latency are set.
What a bunch of partners who
have been working with us.
They've helped us build this
process, and we are super
excited, because they've helped
us learn a lot about what we can
do better, but more importantly
, I think the rap id
rapid pace in which even adding
SmartHome integrations has been
amazing.  We started with three
integrations.  In the keynote,
you heard our team say we have
70 now.  We did most of those in
the last six weeks using this
process.  So we are extremely
excited to open this up to
everyone so we can go even
faster.  So you may say, like
what's next?   The first thing
is everyone leave here, don't go
to the concert.  Build a
SmartHome App, and then go to
the concert.  Right, but there's
other things you may want to
check out.  There are going to
be more device support and
features coming in the next
couple of months as David said.
All of these are on display in
the sand box.  If you go to the
Assistant sand box, the IoT sand
box, they're already on display
and running in production which
is awesome.  And the last one
is that we work really closely
with the Assistant SDk team.  If
you're thinking about how do I
actually imbed the Assistant
into my device, check out the
Assistant SDK.  I think we flew
through this quickly so we have
a couple of minutes left, so
we're more than happy to answer
any questions you guys may have.
side.
>> Microphone's right here if
you want to ask a question.
Assistant to open the slide,
like PPT.
>> Repeat the question one more
time.
>> Use the Google Assistant like
, show me new slide.
>> Oh, yeah. So for on our side
, we more think about the
hardware, not the actual
software piece, but that's a
great thing you should think
about building and actions on
Google platform allow you to do
that.
>> Okay, thank you.
Cool.  Well, thank you, guys,
so much for coming out.
[applause]
>> Have a great IO.
Services Provided By:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO  80132
800-825-5234
www.captionfirst.com
***
This text is being provided in a
realtime format.  Communication
Access Realtime Translation
(CART) or captioning are
provided in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
SAN JOSE, CALIFORNIA
MAY 18, 2017
5:30
PT
STAGE 3
5:30 PT
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
1-877-825-5234
+001-719-481-9835
www.captionfirst.com
This text is being provided in a
realtime format.  Communication
Access Realtime Translation
(CART) or captioning are
provided in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
***
Test.
Coming up - Google Play Awards
at 6:30 p.m.
Google I/O 2017
San Jose, California.
All right.  Who's ready for
tonight?   [Cheering and
applause].
There's no winners here.  All
right.  Thank you guys for
coming.  We're super excited for
you, and congratulations on
being nominees.  Tonight should
be super
fun.  We're really excited and
we hope you guys are too.  Quick
logistics for this evening,
when or if you hear your name
called as a winner, please come
up to this side of the stage
here.  The presenter will hand
you the award
.  Be prepared.  It's heavy.
You'll stop, get a good look at
the photographer, and exit the
side of the stage, and we'll
actually take the award for you,
and you can go back to your
seat, and then afterwards, we'll
rightfully give you your award
back.  So enter, exit, and good
luck to everyone, if there are
any questions.
Good luck, everyone.  Thank
you.
So, yeah, please only use this
stairway, just because this one
is going to be really hard to
use.  Okay.
GOOGLE I/O 2017
SAN JOSE, CALIFORNIA
MAY 18, 2017
6:30 P.M. PASK TIME
STAGE 3
GOOGLE PLAY
AWARDS
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
1-877-825-5234
+001-719-481-9835
www.captionfirst.com
This text is being provided in a
realtime format.  Communication
Access Realtime Translation
(CART) or captioning are
provided in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
***
GOOGLE I/O 2017
SAN JOSE, CALIFORNIA
MAY 18, 2017
6:30 P.M. PASK TIME
STAGE 3
GOOGLE PLAY AWARDS
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
1-877-825-5234
+001-719-481-9835
www.captionfirst.com
***
This text is being provided in a
realtime format.  Communication
Access Realtime Translation
(CART) or captioning are
provided in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
***
Welcome to the 2017 Google
Play A wards.
Please welcome Purnima Kochikar
, director of Apps and games
business development.
Good evening, and welcome to
the second annual Google Play A
wards.
[Cheering and applause]
year at I/O to celebrate your
amazing work.  Behind every
great App is a creative vision
and a remarkable team.  Today,
we celebrate you, your vision
and your teams.
It's a privilege for us at
Google to be part of your
amazing work.  You build
beautiful apps, successful
businesses, and touch lives of
people around the world, and you
challenge us to innovative on
our platforms and keep pace with
your imagination.
about the diversity of the
nominees in today's categories.
From Apps that teach kids to
code to ones that allow you to
play with friends around the
world, from Think Tank to
feeding the hungry, it is
amazing to see the many
different countries you come
from and the many, many
different apps that you are
building.
And as where I stand, it is
exciting for me to also see all
the wonderful things that
connect you.  You have a
relentless focus on your users,
innovation hunger to pick up the
latest features and
capabilities, and a dedication
to build beautiful apps that
engage.
In looking at your apps, the
judging panel, of course, took
into account innovation and
design, but also thought about
things like app quality that
actually lead to user happiness.
Things like, does your app
drain battery?   None of us
likes that, do we?   And judging
by the ratings and reviews on
Google Play, we are sure that
our users and your users agree
that your apps exemplify the
best that is there in Android
and Play.  So with no further
ado, let's get the show started!
standout Indie.  Please welcome
Jamil Moledina, game strategic
lead, Google Play.
I ran into an indie games
startup.  I learned firsthand
how risky innovation is for a
small studio, but at the same
time, innovation may be all you
have to stand out.  It's then
incumbent upon platforms to
shine a spotlight on those
developers that dare to try
something new, and helping
operate that spotlight at Google
is one way that I've been able
to give back to this rich,
diverse community.  Indis have
inherent value in that they
demonstrate the endless
capabilities of what small teams
can build.  They pour their
heart and souls into their work.
They embody diversity, and
often, they take unexpected
leaps introducing us to unique
game controls and breakthrough
story ideas, all stemming from a
deep passion for their art
while using games as a medium to
express the human condition.
This year's nominees deliver on
all counts.  Let's take a look.
Standout Indie nominees are:
Causality.  KINGD:  New Lands.
ingdom:  New
Lands.  Mars Mars.  Mushroom 11.
Reigns.
Standout Indie.
The winner of this year's
award is the epitome of a
beautiful game experience on
mobile.  Itself stunning
graphics, melancholic soundtrack
and unique and native game
controls give gamers the perfect
immersion into the challenges
and outcomes of this world.  I
fell in love the first time I
played the early version of this
game and am thrilled that we
can share it with everyone on
Google Play.  The winner of this
year's Standout indie award is
Mushroom 11 by Untame.
[Cheering and applause]
welcome Larissa Fonaine,
director and global head of apps
business development, Google
Play.
[Applause]
about taking risks and fuelling
innovation.  Small and scrappy,
the most exciting startups
inspire all of us by taking
great ideas and turning them
into breakout success stories.
At Play, we care a lot about
making sure that startups can
find their audience and that
users can find the great and
exciting apps that are coming
from this community.  In
addition to innovating inside
their own apps, startups are
often early adopters of new
platforms and new technology
features, which means they're
creating some of the most
interesting Android experiences
today, and they're also becoming
some of our best partners.  So
now that we've set that bar
really high, let's take a look
at the
nominees.
Standout Startup nominees are:
Cast
Box.  Digit.
Discord.
HOOKED.
Simple Habit.
Standout Startup.
This
year's winner built an original
experience by rethinking
fiction for the texting
generation.  They use an every
day mobile behavior to deliver
creative and captivating stories
that immerse the user in the
narrative in real time.  As a
lifelong bookworm, I'm thrilled
to announce that this year's
standout startup award winner is
HOOKED by Telepathic.
[Cheering and applause]
Please welcome David Singleton,
VP, Engineering.
developers to reach users with
glanceable information
throughout their day.  With Wear
2.0, our latest build, we
introduced standalone apps.
These allow developers to build
experiences that operate
independently without requiring
the phone nearby.  The new apps
being created helped simplify
life's daily activities, such as
staying informed, exploring
what's nearby, and accessing
guides and metrics to improve
your personal health and workout
routines.  And while Android
Wear is still a platform in
itself infancy, we are so
excited by the support from both
developers and hardware
manufacturers and I hope more of
you will try it out.  Let's
take a look at this year's
nominees.
nominees are Bring!
Foursquare.
Lifesum.
Runtastic Running and Fitness.
Seven.
Best Android Wear experience.
The winner of this year's
award offers a smart and sleek
experience utilizing the
convenience of GPS and other key
sensors.  This year's winner of
best Android Wear Experience is
Runtastic Running&Fitness.
welcome s   Sascha Prueter,
Director, Android TV.
photo.
[Laughter]
So while many mobile
developers built for the small
screen such as ones just
presented, this category
celebrates audiences through
Android TV and take advantage of
the larger screen in the house.
Building for the large screen
allows developers to explore new
menu and UI options to create
rich media experiences that
drive really long session times.
And thanks to a strong
developer community -- so thanks
to you -- the TV app section is
fast growing and a successful
category.  The number of TV apps
in the Play Store on Android TV
have doubled since Google I/O
last year and now exceeding
3,000 apps and games.  So let's
look at the nominees for this
year's Best TV Experience.
Best TV Experience nominees
are:  AbemaTV.
Haystack TV.
KkBOX.
NetFlix.
Red Bull TV.
Best TV Experience.
This year's winner has
completely updated their UI to
provide a fresh, best-in-class
TV user experience, using simple
controls and beautiful designs,
they give
users a content-rich offering
with high quality, live, and on-
demand content.  The winner of
this year's Best TV Experience
is Red Bull TV by Red Bull.
Please welcome Clay Bavor, VP
Virtual Reality.
So VR is cool because it can,
like that guy, make you feel
like you're somewhere else,
whether you're on a beach with
scary crab zombies or searching
an ancient ship wreck for VR
treasure.  It really puts you
right in the action, and you
don't just get to see what it's
like to be somewhere else, but
really experience it.  So Day
dream is our platform for mobile
virtual reality, and thanks to
the passion and creativity of
some amazing developers, there's
a large and growing library of
really cool things to experience
and do.  You can explore
different worlds.  You can step
inside games.  You can just kick
back and watch your own
personal cinema.  We've been so
impressed with what we've seen
so far.  And so it's my huge
pleasure to announce the
nominees for Best VR Experience.
are:  The Arcslinger.
Gunjack 2:  End of Shift.  Meko
rama VR.
The Turning Forest.
Virtual Virtual Reality.
Best VR Experience.
I love them all.  But the
winner -- it's hard to describe
the kind of crazy off-the-wall
experience of exploring 50
different alternate realities
doing weird jobs for bored art
official intelligences, all
while trying to uncover the back
story of the kind of
shady company apativeitude, the
virtual later system of the
future.  You'll just have to try
it.  The winner of this year's
VR Experience is Virtual Virtual
Reality by Tender Claws.
tivitude,
the virtual later system of the
future.  You'll just have to
try it.  The winner of this
year's VR Experience is Virtual
Virtual Reality by Tender Claws.
welcome Amit Singh, VP of
Business Operations, VR.
Clay was talking about, virtual
reality can take you anywhere.
Augmented reality, AR, can bring
anything to you, as if it was
there.  And we've been working
on a project for a while called
Tango.  It allows phones to send
just like we do, depth, scale,
perception, precision.  It can
really bring objects as if they
were right there.  And people
have done amazing things with it
.  You can shop for a couch,
make sure it fits the
environment you're in, or you
can invite dinosaurs and play
with them in your kitchen.  And
so let's take a look at the
nominees who have built these
amazing experiences powered by
Tango.
Best AR Experience nominees
are:  Crayolea Color Blaster.
a Color
Blaster.
Dinosaurs Among Us.  Holo.
Wayfair View.
WOORLD.
Best AR Experience.
Very, very tough choice.
These are all great.  You must
try them out.  They're
all actually in the part over
there with the Daydream and
Tango experience.  The one
that's the winner really brings
whimsey fancifulness.  It really
lets you be in the your space
and decorate the wall.  It's
really fun.  Super fun to play.
The winner is WOORLD by Funome
na.
Please welcome Shazia Makhdumi,
Global Head of Family Education
and Partnerships, Google Play.
Hi, everyone.  So I was the
mom of two boys age 9 and 10,
and who are captivated by worlds
of harry Potter and Minecraft.
I love how great apps and games
can capture kids' imagination
and fire their creativity.  But,
in addition, the right apps
also go beyond that.  They help
change parents' perception of
mobile devices, beyond
electronic babysitters to tools
that help their kids develop
skills, to explore, to thrive,
and to learn.  Now, if only
someone could build an app that
could keep my kids that same age
for.
However, developers in our
Designed for Families program,
while they don't do that, they
use intuitive and kid-friendly
design, together with age-
appropriate content to engage
and inspire kids, with colorful
characters, creative visuals,
and realistic sounds, they build
fun, educational, and safe
experiences on mobile devices.
So this year's nominees offer a
diverse lineup sure to appeal to
any household with kids.  Let's
take a look.
Best App for Kids nominees are
:  Animal Jam-Play Wild!
Hot Wheels, Race Off.  Teeny
Titans.
Think!   Think!
Toca Life:  Vacation.  Best App
for Kids.
So just like it's really hard,
as any parent would know to
pick your favorite child, you
know, we've had to make a choice
here.  We love them all.  But
can you imagine anything more
fun than showing off your style
with characters that express the
real you?   This year's winner
teaches kids how to use their
creativity to build, explore,
and share, all while learning
about science.  The winner of
this year's Best App for Kids is
Animal Jam-Play Wild!   By Wild
Works.
welcome Jason Titus, VP of
Engineering, Developer Product
Group.
about mobile phones is how they
let us play together across
continents and take time,
whether it's in line or on the
bus, and actually make time
playing with your friends.  In
recent years, we've seen amazing
improvements with multiplayer
games taking advantage of the
huge numbers of mobile users, as
well as the advanced technology
in today's phones.  Multiplayer
games come in all genres and
sizes.  But the thing that they
have in common is the amazing
ability to bring us together.  A
true multiplayer game is built
from the ground up, and this
year's nominees are some of the
best.  Let's take a look.
Best Multiplayer Game nominees
are:  Dawn of Titans.
FIFA Mobile.
Hearthstone.
Lords Mobile.
Modern Strike Online!
Best Multiplayer Game.
This year's winner reaches a
global audience of nearly 190
countries.  It's developed by a
team of 30 different
nationalities, which seems so
appropriate.  Through the
developer's continual push for
excellence through iteration and
experimentation, this app is
constantly evolving to make
learning one of your favorite
leisure activities -- to make
leisure activities.  The winner
of this year's Best Multiplayer
Game is Hearthstone by Blizzard
Entertainment.
Jamie Rosenberg, VP Android and
Play business.
have all of you here.  It's
amazing to think about the
innovation in mobile apps over
the past few years.  We've seen
so many great examples of that
already tonight.  As smartphones
have become more powerful, you
all have kept pace by finding
more ways for our phones to help
us in our daily lives.  Great
apps help us create, explore,
stay fit, organize, learn, and
so much more.  And the very best
of these do so through
excellence in design and
performance, thoughtful use of
the capabilities of our devices,
and often a bit of fun.  Let's
take a look at the nominees for
Best App.
Best App nominees are:  City
mapper.
Fabulous.
Memrise.
Money Lover.
Quik.
Best App.
So I'm just going to say, this
app takes an activity that can
be a drag and makes it a ton of
fun.  The Google Play award for
Best App goes to Memrise.
Sameer Samat, VP Play and
Android.
smartphones for a very long time
, and I think we can all agree
that games have come a long way
on mobile.  It's exciting to see
so many of you using
capabilities on the platform to
bring amazing experiences.  You
have changed the way people
think about mobile gaming, by
presenting rich storylines, mind
-blowing graphics, and bringing
out the competitor in each of us
.  With 2 billion Android
devices, developers have the
freedom to build fun and
engaging experiences knowing
that an audience is just one tap
away.  Let's take a look at
this year's nominees.
Best Game nominees are:
Choices.
Fire Emblem Heroes.
Lineage 2 Revolution.
Pokemon Go.
Transformers:  Forged to Fight.
Best Game.
Now, all these titles are in
spiring.  This year's winner
brings console quality graphics
to mobile, showcasing gaming on
Android.  Through stunning 3D
graphics and incredible
technical performance, they are
bringing iconic characters to
life and offering an
inspiration of how gaming can
truly be on mobile.  The winner
of this year's Best Game award
is Transformers:  Forged to
Fight.
[Cheering and applause]
Please welcome Hiroshi
Lockheimer.  SVP Platforms and
Ecosystems.
How's everyone doing?
How's everyone doing, having
fun?
[Cheering and applause]
That's good.  Before we get to
this, I just wanted to say a
quick thank you, you know,
Android, Google Play, we would
be nowhere without you, so a big
thank you to the developer
community.  Thank you very much
.
[Cheering and applause]
All right.  Well, at Google,
our mission is to organize the
world's information and make it
universally accessible and
useful.  Universally accessible.
With this mission in mind and
that phrase in mind, it's with
great pleasure I get to
introduce this new category Best
Accessibility Experience.  Here
, we will highlight developers
that offer innovate ive
solutions to assist in different
disability needs and overcoming
challenges.  They deliver
intuitive experiences and
empower individuals through
mobile apps.  They foster
communication, build
independence and have the
capability of connecting users
in very meaningful ways.  Let's
take a look at the nominees.
Best Accessibility Experience
nominees are:  A Blind Legend.
Eye-D.
IFTTT.
Open Sesame!
SwiftKey Symbols.
Best Accessibility Experience.
All right.  Well, the winner
of this year's award is a brill
iantly designed platform
offering an experience inclusive
for users and developers with
various needs.  They simplify
daily tasks, especially for
those with vision and motor im
pairments to increase
productivity and independence.
Please join me in congratulating
this year's winner of this Best
Accessibility Experience, IFTTT
.
I'm back.  I was really
hoping for my head shot again,
but you'll get it live instead.
So developer ecosystem has an
extremely diverse makeup.  The
product of this breadth of
culture, personal interests, and
creative vision produces a lot
of truly amazing work.  You make
a lot of amazing work, thank
you.  This category looks for
apps that create meaningful
social impact for a broad
spectrum of people around the
world while taking full
advantage of the platform.  It
rewards developers who challenge
themselves to promote themes of
contribution, accessibility,
and knowledge sharing, through
creative solutions that address
issues locally, regionally, and
even globally.  So let's take a
look at the nominees.
Best Social Impact nominees
are:  Charity Miles.
Peek Acuity.
ProDeaf.
Sea Hero Quest.
ShareTheMeal.
Best Social Impact.
This year's winner generates
large-scale reach to fight a
major global issue.  The app
uses a simple interface to drive
awareness and engagement of a
major cause.  They are a
tremendous partner, and I
encourage you all to try out
their new Instant App launching
here at I/O.  The winner of this
year's Best Social Impact award
is Share the Meal.
Kochikar.
it?
[Cheering and applause]
to all the nominees and the
winners!
[Cheering and applause]
when he said, without you, tools
and our platforms are nothing,
so we thank you for your
commitment, for your innovation,
and I can't wait to see you
here next year to see what you
will have built between now and
then.  So thank you all for
coming.  I hope you enjoy the
rest of the show.  There's a big
show at the amphitheater at
8:00.  We hope to see you there.
Thank you very much.